JUDICIARY -- CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
CENTER SKINNER I'M HERE ENTER
MORLOCK.
SENATOR ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT SO -- ONE SECOND
.
OUR FIRST TWO WISHES ARE VOTE
ONLY BUT I'M IN A SKIP -- RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE ARE A MISSING ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS AND I'M GONNA GO
TO ISSUE. THREE I'M [inaudible]
THE A ONE SECOND.
I'M GONNA GO TO ISSUE THREE
WHICH IS THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING
POST.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF POST MANNY
ALVAREZ HERE -- AND WHO ARE YOU
JOINT [inaudible]
BY.
I'M THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MARIA SANDOVAL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHOEVER'S GONNA OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
US SENATOR AND LEASING GENTLEMAN
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT THIS
BUDGET HEARING.
MY NAME IS MANNY ALVAREZ I SERVE
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING OR POST
AS WE ARE COMMONLY KNOWN.
SEE TO MY LEFT IS A MISS MARIA
SAND OF ALL THE POST ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR FIELD
SERVICES.
THIS IS MADE UP OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE.
BY SETTING HIRING STANDARDS THE
LIVING TRAINING CONDUCTING
AUDITS AND SETTING REGULATIONS
FOR FORTY ONE POLICE ACADEMIES
AND JUST OVER SIX HUNDRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
WHICH VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE
OPPOSE PROGRAM. EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND FULL TIME PEACE
OFFICERS EIGHT THOUSAND RESERVE.
PEACE OFFICERS AND EIGHT
THOUSAND PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS ARE SERVED BY POST.
GOVERNOR NUISANCE PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR POST INCLUDES A
THIRTY FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLAR.
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION.
CONSISTING OF FOURTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION.
FOR RESTORATION AND CREATION OF
NEW.
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AND TWENTY MILLION FOR USE OF DE
ESCALATION.
USE OF FORCE AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING.
THE POST BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
ADDRESSES THE FUNDING AND THREE
CUSTOMARY MANNERS [inaudible]
ADMINISTRATION.
TRAINING DELIVERY AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE.
OR AGENCY REIMBURSEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY DISPLAYING THE
FUNDING IN THE B. C. P.
UTILIZING THESE CATEGORIES DOES
NOT CLEARLY DELINEATE.
HOW CLOSE WILL UTILIZE THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR THE USE OF FORCE?
THE ESCALATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING.
YES I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO ADDRESS THIS.
MOST OF THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL BE DISTRIBUTED AS
LOCAL ASSISTANCE OR AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENT TO CITY.
AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS WHICH
PARTAKE IN USE OF FORCE DE
ESCALATION AND MENTAL HEALTH
TRAINING.
WE'VE DISTRIBUTED TO YOU A COPY
OF A REPORT CONTAINING POST
TRAINING USE OF FORCE DE
ESCALATION AND MENTAL HEALTH.
EACH ONE OF THOSE COURSES
CONTAINS.
CONCEPTS IN TOPICS THAT ADDRESS
EACH ONE OF THOSE THREE AREAS.
IS IS DEMONSTRATED IN THIS
REPORT.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT POST CERTIFIED
TRAINING COURSES WHICH COVER
THESE THREE AREAS.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS POST IS
AVERAGED 460-001-0090 EIGHT
COURSE COMPLETIONS EACH YEAR.
A COURSE COMPLETIONS MEANS ONE
PERSON COMPLETED EACH COURSE.
AND THAT'S ONE PERSON COULD HAVE
COMPLETED MULTIPLE COURSES.
THE MAJORITY OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT COURSES HAVE
EITHER BEEN DE FUNDED BY POST
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS DUE
TO BUDGET CONSTRAINTS.
OR POST IS SIMPLY NEVER
REIMBURSED FOR THIS TYPE OF
TRAINING.
POST IS NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
CONVERTING ALL TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT COURSES TO BE FULLY
FUNDED FOR LOCAL.
EIGHT LOCAL ASSISTANCE OR AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENT.
FROM A BUDGET STANDPOINT.
POST ESTIMATES THAT ONE EIGHT
OUR FULLY FUNDED TRAINING COURSE.
WILL COST POST A MINIMUM OF ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER STUDENT IF
TRAVEL IS NOT IN THE TRAINING.
IS NOT INVOLVED IN THE TRAINING.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS A STUDENT IF TRAVEL MUST
BE TAKEN TO PARTICIPATE IN
TRAINING.
THUS USING THE AVERAGE NUMBER
460-001-0090 EIGHT COURSE
COMPLETIONS.
YEAR AT A RATE OF A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER DAY THE QUEETS TO
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE OR AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENT.
OR ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION.
WHEN THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR NUMBERS USED?
OF COURSE NOT ALL TRAINING WILL
REQUIRE TRAVEL.
BUT THESE NUMBERS ONLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ONE EIGHT HOUR COURSE.
MANY OF THE EXISTING TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT MANY OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
EXISTING COURSES ARE MORE THAN
EIGHT HOURS.
IN LENGTH AND SOME ARE AS LONG
AS FORTY HOURS.
THE US POST COULD VERY
CONSERVATIVE CONSERVATIVELY
DISTRIBUTE FOUR POINT SIX TO
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE THE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AGENCY
REIMBURSEMENT.
IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ADDITIONALLY THESE NUMBERS DO
NOT INCLUDE ANY FORM OF BACK
FILL FUNDING WHICH THE BCP ALSO
REQUESTS AND POST ANTICIPATES.
USING FOR THIS TYPE OF TRAINING.
LOS IS ARTICULATED A VISION OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO FURTHER THESE
THREE TRAINING INITIATIVES.
AND IN EARLY JANUARY.
TWENTY NINETEEN HOST DISTRIBUTED
PORTENTS TO ALL POST AGENCIES
REQUESTING THEIR OWN INDEPENDENT.
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW DE ESCALATION
AND MENTAL HEALTH COURSES.
WHICH WILL BE COUPLED WITH FULL
FUNDING BY POST.
THUS WE ANTICIPATE POST WILL
HAVE ILL SOON HAVE MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT COURSES.
IF APPROVED.
POSTAL WE'VE THE BASIC CONCEPTS
OF DE ESCALATION USE OF FORCE
AND MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING IN
THE FOLLOWING POST COURSES.
THE ACADEMY INSTRUCTOR
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
COLLEGE EXECUTIVE DEVELOPMENT
COURSE.
FIELD TRAINING OFFICER TRAINING.
MANAGEMENT COURSE.
SUPERVISORY LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE
AND THE SUPERVISORY COURSE.
I DID NOT MENTION THE BASIC
POLICE ACADEMY BECAUSE IN
JANUARY.
TWENTY NINETEEN COAST ALREADY
INITIATED A PILOT TRAINING
PROGRAM AT THREE OF THE FORTY
ONE POLICE ACADEMIES.
THE PILOT TRAINING INCLUDES DE
ESCALATION.
TRAINING AS WELL AS PROCEDURAL
JUSTICE AND TACTICAL MEDICAL
CARE.
USE OF FORCE AND MENTAL HEALTH --
TRAINING IS ALREADY INCORPORATED
INTO THE PERMANENT BASIC ACADEMY
CURRICULUM.
INTOTAL. EIGHT PROGRAMS I JUST
FIFTEEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS PER
YEAR.
AND APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
OF THOSE FIFTEEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS AND WILL HELP SHAPE
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
IN BOTH PUBLIC.
AND PRIVATE SECTORS IT IS WELL
ESTABLISHED THAT THOSE IN
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AND
TREMENDOUSLY INFLUENCE THE
DIRECTION.
AND CULTURE OF AN ORGANIZATION.
EACH SERGEANT LIEUTENANT AN
EXECUTIVE SERVES AS A FORCE
MULTIPLIER TO INFLUENCE DOZENS
IF NOT HUNDREDS OF OR EVEN
THOUSANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL.
IN THEIR CHAIN OF COMMAND.
BY WEAVING THESE CRITICAL.
TOPICS ROUTE THE VAST SPECTRUM
OF POST.
WITH THE RETURN ON AND THEY'VE
WE ARE CONFIDENT THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WILL BE EXPONENTIALLY
GREATER AND IF THE TRAINING WERE
LIMITED TO STAND ALONE COURSES.
POST ESTIMATES THIS WILL RESULT
IN EXPENDITURES IN
ADMINISTRATION TRAINING AND
LOCAL ASSISTANCE BUT WILL
PRIMARILY LEVERAGE A SERIES OF
TRAINING CONTRACTS TO EXPAND OF
TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
AS I NOTED EARLIER POST IS
PILOTING DE ESCALATION TRAINING
IN THE BASIC ACADEMY.
AND APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
CADETS WILL RECEIVE THIS
TRAINING BY THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AS OF TODAY.
THE FEEDBACK RECEIVED BY THE
THREE PILOT ACADEMIES AND MOST
OF THE STUDENTS HAS BEEN
POSITIVE.
SHOULD POST WHICH TO REIMBURSE
FOR THE BASIC ACADEMY DE
ESCALATION TRAINING.
OR SHOULD THE DE ESCALATION
TRAINING BECOME MANDATORY UNDER
COMMISSION REGULATION.
OR LAW IT WILL RESULT IN AN
ADDITIONAL LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AGENCY REIMBURSEMENT OF BETWEEN
200-523-0070 FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
POST IS CURRENTLY UNABLE TO
REIMBURSE FOR THIS TRAINING
BECAUSE THE REIMBURSEMENT CAP.
IS SET AT SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR HOURS OF TRAINING THE RATE
OF FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY.
OF THE FORTY ONE K. ACADEMIES.
THE SHORTEST ACADEMY IS
CURRENTLY SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
HOURS WELL OVER THE SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY FOR OUR REIMBURSEMENT CAP.
THE B. C. P. REQUEST FUNDING FOR
BASIC CATAMARANS DIRECTION SO
THE CAP CAN BE RAISED EIGHT
HUNDRED HOURS OF TRAINING AT A
RATE OF SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
I'M ALMOST DONE MADAM CHAIR I
PROMISE.
THE QUESTION SO OKAY -- WE GET
TO THOSE THE BURN OFF I'VE GOT
THIRTY SECONDS LEFT.
IN THE B. C. P. POST REQUESTED
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR INSTRUCTOR DEVELOPMENT.
OF THAT AMOUNT SIX IS EXPECTING.
TO USE APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TO PROVIDE YEARLY
DE ESCALATION IMPLICIT BIAS AND
USE OF FORCE TRAINING TO ALL
BASIC ACADEMY INSTRUCTORS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CLOSE IS IN DISCUSSIONS WITH ONE
OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
DELIVER THIS TRAINING IN PERSON.
TO ONE ACADEMY AT A TIME.
THE PROPOSAL IS FOR FIVE TEAMS
OF INSTRUCTORS TO DELIVER YOUR
EARLY TRAINING TO EACH OF THE
FORTY ONE ACADEMIES.
THIS IS ALSO IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY GENCY
TO DEVELOP.
UNDER CONTRACT ES DE ESCALATION
AND USE OF FORCE SYMPOSIUM WITH
WELL KNOWN INDUSTRY EXPERTS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA ON FOR SOME
EXECUTIVES.
AND SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE SYMPOSIUM
WILL BE TO DEVELOP THE
ESCALATION CONSIDERATIONS AND
GUIDELINES FOR CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
POSTAL ADDRESS SUCH THINGS AS
POLICY TACTICS TECHNIQUES AND
COMMUNITY POLICING.
WE ANTICIPATE A SERIES OF BEST
PRACTICES WILL BE DEVELOPED.
AND PUBLISHED BY POST.
POST WE USE THESE BEST PRACTICES
AS A FOUNDATION FOR ITS LEGACY --
COURSE IT LEGACY INSTRUCTION
COURSES.
CLOSE WILL HOLD TO TRAINING
SYMPOSIUMS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXECUTIVES TO COVER THESE TOPICS
WHEN NORTH AND ONE SOUTH.
MOST ESTIMATES THE TO DO ALL
THIS WILL REQUIRE A COMBINATION
OF TRAINING AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AGENCY REIMBURSEMENT TOTALING UP
TO SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CLOSE WILL UTILIZE THESE
GUIDELINES TO CREATE NEW
TRAINING COURSES FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHER. TO CREATE ONE
NEW TRAINING COURSE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS AND ONE NEW
COURSE FOR PEACE OFFICERS.
LASTLY THE BCP REQUESTED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TRAINING
MONIES FOR THE QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROGRAM.
THE QUALITY ASSURANCE PROGRAMS
DE FUNDED BY POSTING.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN POST WILL
UTILIZE UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THAT MONEY TO AUDIT
INSTRUCTION RELATED TO DE
ESCALATION.
USE OF FORCE AND MENTAL HEALTH.
AGAIN WE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
US TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
YOU BEFORE I'M WE HEAR FROM LA --
AND OTHERS.
THE FIRST THING I WANT.
TO DISCUSS.
IS THE FACT THAT THE BCP
PROVIDED BY POST.
GIVES A VERY DIFFERENT NARRATIVE.
THEN THE SUMMARY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET [inaudible]
I'M.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUMMARY
DESCRIBES THE TWENTY MILLION
COMPONENT THAT IS ONGOING AND AN
EXTENSION OF THE FUNDING WE
PROVIDED LAST YEAR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
WHICH WOULD BE FOR THE TRAINING
AND PROCEDURES RELATED TO FORCE
DE ESCALATION OFFICER WELLNESS
IMPLICIT BIAS IN VARIOUS THINGS
LIKE THAT.
NOW THE PCP THAT POST SUBMITTED
DOES NOT COVER HOW ANY OF THIRTY
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION WOULD GO
TO THOSE EFFORTS AND WHILE YOU
MENTION SOME IN YOUR VERBAL
TESTIMONY.
WRITTEN DOCUMENT WE HAVE IS A
VCP [inaudible]
I'M.
THE OTHER THING NOW YOU DON'T
ADDRESS THIS YET I WANT TO FIRST
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHY THEY'RE
SO DIFFERENT [inaudible]
BUT ADDITIONALLY.
WE PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING
[inaudible] FOUR I FOCUS ON THE
DEAL ESCALATION [inaudible]
AND TO DATE.
IT'S BEEN NINE MONTHS. THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND HAS BEEN SPENT.
AND YET WE HAVE BC P. BEFORE US
TO AUGMENT THE ENTIRE BUDGET OF
POST BY THIRTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION [inaudible]
N. I LATER THERE'S ANOTHER
DOCUMENT THAT INDICATES THAT.
YOU ESTIMATE THAT YOU'LL SPEND
TEN MILLION OF THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WE GAVE.
BY THE END OF TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BLACK STILL INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR.
AND I SUPPOSE OUR FIRST THING I.
**** HOW YOU PULL THAT OFF WHEN
YOU'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO SPEND
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND AND NINE
MONTHS SO THAT'S AND MILLION
THAT'S QUITE A LEAP.
BUT THEN IF YOU'RE ANTICIPATING
TO SPEND THE MONEY WE ALREADY
GAVE YOU.
THROUGH TO THE END OF NINETEEN
TWENTY WHY SHOULD WE GIVE YOU
ANOTHER. THIRTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION CERTAINLY BUT THERE MAY
BE SOME JUSTIFICATION FOR A
PORTION OF THAT.
BUT IT'S HARD.
TO JUSTIFY THE OTHER BUT I
JUMPED IN I DON'T WANT THE
ANSWER THAT FIRST I WANT TO
FIRST GET THE BOTTOM OF WHY.
GOVERNOR SUMMARY IS ONE THING B.
C. P. IS ANOTHER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
ERIN EDWARDS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- I UNDERSTAND THERE
MAY BE SOME CONFUSION BETWEEN
WHAT WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THE AND THE B. C. P.
AND I CERTAINLY.
DON'T THINK THE INTENT WAS TO
HOW TO HIDE THE BALL ABOUT
HOWARD INTENDING TO SPEND THE
MORNING AND MISTER NECESSARILY
CALLING IT A HIDE THE BALL I'M
JUST CALL LET'S RECONCILE SURE
BUDGET OF MY HEARING.
SURE AND I I THINK THE THE
INTENT OF THE STATEMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BDGET WAS TO
INDICATE THAT THE GOVERNOR FULLY
SUPPORTS -- EXPANDING DE
ESCALATION MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING -- I THINK
THE LEGEND HE APPRECIATES THE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP ON
PROVIDING THAT FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR AND I THINK
SHARES THE COMMITMENT TO
FURTHERING THOSE GOALS AND I
THINK -- THERE WAS NEVER AN AND
TIMES THAT W WOULD SIMPLY RE
FIND THE SAME THINGS THAT WERE
FUNDED ON A ONE TIME BASIS -- IN
THE CURRENT YEAR MANY OF THOSE
THINGS LIKE EQUIPMENT PURCHASES
AND DEVELOPMENT OF CURRICULUM
AREN'T REALLY THINGS THAT YOU
WOULD NECESSARILY DO OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
AND SO I THINK THE IDEA FROM THE
BEGINNING WAS THAT THE
AUGMENTATION ON AN ONGOING BASIS
WOULD BE USED -- TO DO SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT MISTER ALVAREZ
SPOKE TO ABOUT REALLY
INTEGRATING.
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION TRAINING AND DE
ESCALATION TRAINING INTO THE THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF TRAINING THAT
THE THAT POST DELIVERS FROM THE
POINT OF THE BASIC ACADEMY.
THROUGH -- REGULAR ON GOING
TRAININGS AND THAT ALL THE WAY
UP THROUGH SENIOR LEADERSHIP
TRAINING -- I REALLY JUST HAVE
TO BE A HOLISTIC APPROACH IN
WEAVING AND THREW OUT AND I
THINK MAYBE SOME OF THE
CONFUSION IS -- THAT THOSE
EFFORTS REALLY REQUIRE A BROADER
APPROACH AND HOW WE REIMBURSE
LOCALS -- LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FOR ATTENDING TRIP --
TRAININGS AND TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO SIGN FOLKS -- AND SO.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
CONFUSION ABOUT TRYING TO
PINPOINT EXACTLY HOW THOSE
DOLLARS ARE SPENT FOR SPECIFIC.
PROGRAMS IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
DEVELOPING STANDALONE CURRICULUM
IS REALLY ABOUT WEAVING THESE
COMPONENTS INTO EXISTING
TRAININGS -- IN SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT CONFUSION AYE AYE TH I
THINK THAT KIND OF SPEAKS TO
WHAT OUR INTENT IS THOUGH.
OR POST RESPONSE.
I WOULD IMAGINE NOW OBVIOUSLY
[inaudible]
THE M..
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PRESENTED
TO US.
EARLY IN THE YEAR.
AND BY THEIR YOU KNOW WAS ONLY
AT IS A BRIEFER PERIOD OF TIME
BETWEEN THE TIME WE ALLOCATED
THIS ONE TIME ONLY AND WHEN THE
BUDGET WAS SUBMITTED -- BUT
GIVEN WHAT YOU JUST EXPLAINED.
AGAIN THERE'S NOT.
WE BEFORE WE CAN DO UP THE
APPROPRIATE.
OUR TRAINING WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
CURRICULUM WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
EQUIPMENT WE HAVE TO HAVE ALL
THE THINGS YOU REFERENCED.
WHICH YOU'RE RIGHT.
OF THE ALLOCATION OF THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME ONLY WAS
TO GET US IN THAT POSITION TO DO
SO.
AND SINCE WE'RE NOT YET.
IN THAT SITUATION TO DO SO.
WHY WOULD WE NOW CERTAINLY I CAN
APPRECIATE WHY POTENTIALLY IN
THE FUTURE?
WE WOULD GREATLY BE EXPANDING
POST BUDGET BASED ON NOW.
THIS EXPANDED TRAINING THE
CURRICULUM WE HAVE ALL OF THAT.
BUT WHEN WE HAVEN'T WE'RE NOT
EVEN THERE YET.
THIS IS THE DIFFICULTY I'M
HAVING.
YEAH I I CAN APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK THAT THE FROM OUR
STANDPOINT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT POST IS BEING CAREFUL ON
HOW THEY PROCEED WITH SPENDING
THOSE DOLLARS IN THAT.
THEY'RE DOING ENOUGH THOUGHTFUL
AND COMPREHENSIVE AND HOLISTIC
WAY -- I THINK THAT MISTER
ALVAREZ COULD BETTER SPEAK TO
KIND OF EXACTLY HOW MUCH HAS
BEEN SPENT AND AND WHERE THEY'RE
AT AND THAT PROCESS BUT I THINK --
WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO PROCEED
THOUGHTFULLY AND NOT TO RUSH
FORWARD AND AND SPEND THE WAY
AND ON AND ON SPEND THE MONEY IN
A WAY THAT'S NOT GONNA BE AS
ACTIVE.
IS THERE BEFORE MISTER POST ME
MISTER ALVAREZ FOR POST ANSWERS.
IF THERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION
RELATED TO THIS LINE OF
QUESTIONING THAT YOU WANT TO
RAISE A EITHER -- EITHER MEMBER.
BUT IN THE END HE COULD ADDRESS
THAT ONCE YOU PLEASE FEEL FREE
SENATOR MOORLACH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
MYSTRAS -- I AM BRAND NEW TO
THIS COMMITTEE SO MAY I ASK YOU
SOME VERY BASIC QUESTIONS.
WHAT IS YOUR BUSINESS MODEL?
LIKE LIKE A LIKE IF I'M A CPA
BACKGROUND SO I HAVE TO GET
FORTY HOURS A YEAR OF CONTINUING
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION.
I GO THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA'S
CPA FOUNDATION.
NO THERE THERE LIKE AB OUT.
THERE NONPROFIT BUT THEY MAKE A
PROFIT BY MY PAYING.
FOR I COURSES SO REVENUES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE EXPENSES
PAYING FOR YOUR INSTRUCTORS AND
RUNNING THE ROOMS AND WHATEVER
WHAT.
SALAS SAYS I I HAVE.
NO UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR MODELS
I APOLOGIZE THAT.
SO.
WHY DO YOU EVEN NEED FUNDING
FROM THE STATE IF YOU'RE?
CHARGING FOR COURSES OR ARE YOU
NOT CHARGING FOR COURSE WE DO
NOT CHARGE FOR FORCES OKAY THANK
YOU.
SO WHY NOT WHY NOT I'M JUST HELP
ME OUT.
I BELIEVE THE PENAL CODE SAYS IT
WOULD RECEIVE CLOSE TO PROVIDE
STATE AID TO POST PARTICIPATING
AGENCIES PARTICIPATE IN TRAINING
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO THROUGH
LOCALLY.
REIMBURSEMENT.
WE DELIVER TRAINING IN TWO
PRIMARY METHODS ONE WE EITHER
DELIVER IT OURSELVES OR UNDER
CONTRACT WE DEVELOP THE
CURRICULUM AND ITS DEPLOYED.
OR AGENCIES AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND PRIVATE PRESENTERS
SPRING TRAINING TO US FOR US TO
REVIEW AND CERTIFY.
AND WE MAY OR MAY NOT FUND THAT
TYPE OF TRAINING.
SO AGENCIES ARE FOR THE MOST
PART HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE LEAST
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS -- TO
PAY FOR THE SALARIES OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND SUCH WHILE WE'VE
BEEN.
AT TRAINING SOME OF THE TRAINING
IS NOT FUNDED SO THEY HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEIR OWN TRAVEL AND
SUCH SO.
WE PAY TO EITHER DELIVERY OR WE
FIND SOME OF THE TRAINING WE
HAVE BEEN FUNDING MANDATED
TRAINING FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
ANYTHING THAT WE REQUIRE THEM TO
DO FOR INSTANCE TO BE FIELD
TRAINING OFFICER YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A POST COURSE WE FULLY
PAY FOR THAT.
BUT SOME OF THE OTHER STUFF WE
HAVE NOT SO OUR MODEL IS.
EVERY PIECE OFFICER ACROSS THE
STATE HAS TO RECEIVE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF CONTINUING EDUCATION
TRAINING EVERY TWO YEARS THAT IS
NOT A LOT.
ON THE AVERAGE PEACE OFFICER IN
CALIFORNIA THIS LAST.
OUR CYCLE AVERAGE FORTY FOUR
POINT THREE HOURS -- AVERAGE THE
SAUCER IN DISPATCHER AVERAGE
FORTY FOUR POINT THREE HOURS OF
TRAINING.
EVERY.
AS IN ALL IN THAT TWO YEAR CYCLE
OR I'M SORRY EVERY YEAR DURING
THAT TWO YEAR CYCLE.
THAT NUMBER WE WERE ABLE TO BUMP
UP OVER THIS LAST CYCLE THAT IS
A POSITIVE FOR US FROM FORTY
THREE HOURS TO FORTY FOUR POINT
THREE WITHOUT THEM FEELING IT.
WHICH IS A POSITIVE EITHER THE
TRAININGS MORE EFFICIENT IT'S
DELIVERED IN A IN A BETTER WAY
IF THEIR THEIR TRAINING HOURS
INCREASE WITHOUT INCREASE CASA
WE TRACK.
THAT CONSTANTLY ON WE TRY TO PUT
OUR EMPHASIS ON THE BASED
ECONOMY.
AND ON LEADERSHIP COURSES THAT'S
WHERE OUR FOCUS IS BEEN.
BUT THE BASIC ACADEMY LAST
COUPLE YEARS IS REALLY WHAT'S
TAKEN ON PRIVACY FOR US BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
FOUNDATION.
FOR PEACE OFFICERS WHEN THEY
FIRST START INCLUDING FIELD
TRAINING SO WE'VE TRIED TO
DEVELOP THOSE CURRICULUMS AS
BEST WE CAN TO KEEP AND
CONTEMPORARY. TO INCLUDE SUCH
THINGS AS DE ESCALATION TRAINING
AT THE VERY BEGINNING.
ARM AND I I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
JUST -- TO THIS.
IN TERMS OF LIKE THE ESCALATION
TRAIN WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF
FUNDING [inaudible]
IN.
OCTOBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
ALREADY APPROACH THE COMMISSION
ASKING FOR AUTHORITY TO SIR
REVIEWING WHAT WE COULD DO WITH
DE ESCALATION TRAINING AT THE
ACADEMY.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AGAIN WITH NO FUNDING.
WE'VE GOT APPROVAL FROM THE
COMMISSION TO INCORPORATE.
DE ESCALATION TRAINING IN THE
PILOT IN THE IN THE ACADEMIES
THIS IS BEFORE WE RECEIVED ANY
OF FUNDING FROM THE LEGISLATURE
THE GAP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT THAT
HELPS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
LETTING ME ASK THE RUDIMENTARY.
I HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
TEACHING TWO COURSES FOR POST.
AND THEY WERE WELL ATTENDED
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH.
PHAM LEARNING THANK YOU.
SENATOR BELL DID YOU WANNA
SOMETHING NOW BEFORE WE GET ON
THIS ISSUE -- OKAY SO I GOT THE
THE WERE -- WE PUT IN THE BUDGET
THE MONEY THE EXTRA MONEY.
TO THE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
AND THEN WE SPENT THIRTY SIX
MILLION [inaudible]
SO.
FOR SO WHY WHY OF THE KIND OF
MAKES ME LOOK LIKE AN IDIOT
BECAUSE I GIVE YOU MONEY AND
THEN YOU DON'T SPEND A A GO TO
SPEND IT ON SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU KNOW -- WHY WOULD I WANT TO
DO THAT AGAIN THIS YEAR?
I MEAN YOU GOT THE MONEY YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THE SURE IN AND SPEND
THE MONEY WE GET YOUR LAST YEAR.
KIND OF HARD FOR ME.
TO THINK ABOUT GIVING MONEY.
AGAIN.
IF WE GIVE YOU MONEY FOR CERTAIN
THINGS LASHER UNITS SPEND
[inaudible]
SO -- WAS THERE A REASON WHY IT
AND SPEND THE MONEY WHO TOLD YOU
NOT TO SPEND THE MONEY.
AS I AM.
SIGN LOOK AT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM LAST YEAR
SENATOR.
BROKEN DOWN INTO THREE BUCKETS
ONE IS DE ESCALATION ONE IS
MENTAL HEALTH AND ONE IS -- AN
INNOVATIVE GRANTS PROGRAM IF I
CAN TAKE THEM BACKWARDS SO THE
INNOVATIVE GRANTS PROGRAM IS
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT THAT IS A PROCESS THAT.
WE HAVE NEVER BEEN INVOLVED IN
GRANTS IT TOOK US AWHILE TO GET
THAT PROGRAM SET UP AND THANK.
THANK FULLY.
WE HAD ANOTHER STATE AGENCY TO
HELP US ROUTE PROCESS THIRTY
FOUR POINT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION OF THAT MONEY IS GOING
TO BE AWARDED ON TUESDAY.
WE'VE ALREADY RECEIVED FORTY
FOUR APPLICATIONS FOR GRANTS
FROM CBO'S FROM EDUCATORS AND
FROM AGENCIES.
A MAJORITY OF THAT MONEY WILL GO
TO CBO'S AND I WILL BE WAY TO
THE FOURTH QUARTER SO YOUR
FOURTH QUARTER SPENDING -- ONE
FOURTH OF THE MONEY.
IS THAT THE WAY IT WORKS.
WELL THE OF THREE YEARS WE HAVE
THREE YEARS TO SPELL IS A THREE
YEAR SO YOU GOT.
THE WAY TO THE FOURTH QUARTER OF
THE FISCAL YEAR. TO SPEND THE
MONEY [inaudible]
HELLO. TO START A A GRANTS-PROGRAM FROM SCRATCH ADMITTEDLY
TOOK A SOME TIME WE HAD TO HOLD
PUBLIC HEARINGS WE HAD TO WAIT
FOR THE R. F. P. TO GET.
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND GRANTS
TO COMMAND THEY CAME IN IN LATE
FEBRUARY.
ARM IT DIDN'T TAKE IT TOOK TIME
TO START FROM GROUND ZERO FROM
SOME WE'VE NEVER DONE ADMITTEDLY
BUT THREE POINT FOUR MILLION OF
IT WILL BE AWARDED NEXT WEEK.
THE OTHER IN THE OTHER.
THE OTHER COMPONENTS ARE DE-ESCALATION AND AND MENTAL HEALTH.
SO IN TERMS OF THE DE ESCALATION
TRAINING IT'S FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WE'VE ALREADY STARTED TO
CONVERT SOME OF THE COURSES TO
BEING FULLY FUNDED WHICH TAKE
SOME TIME BECAUSE SOME OF THEM
DO NOT HAVE BUDGETS.
WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO ADD BUDGETS TO
EACH ONE WITH EACH.
WITH EACH PRESENTER AS YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S A WIDE ARRAY OF
COURSES THEY NEED BUDGETS.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE DE
ESCALATION TRAINING IS.
ARM.
A QUICK MEANT I THINK FIVE
MILLION OF THAT MONEY COULD BE
USED FOR EQUIPMENT FOR DE
ESCALATION TRAINING PRIMARILY
FOR FORCE OPTION SIMULATORS ARE
VIRTUAL REALITY.
TRAINING WE'VE HAD MEETINGS WITH
FIVE DIFFERENT.
VENDORS IN TERMS OF UPDATING OUR
EXISTING EQUIPMENT -- FOR FOR
SERGEANT SIMULATORS.
THE PROBLEM WITH IT IS WE HAVE
NOT FOUND A VENDOR AT THIS POINT
OR AFP OR A PLATFORM.
THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO CREATE THE
SCENARIOS YOU BASICALLY GET THE
SCENARIOS FROM A VENDOR AND
THEY'RE VERY QUICK IF YOU'VE
PROBABLY SEEN THEM THERE FIFTEEN
SECOND SHOOT DON'T SHOOT.
TYPE OF SCENARIOS WHICH WERE NOT
HAPPY WITH WE WANT TO MODEL THEM
IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATION SKILLS
AND AND MULTIPLE BRANCHES AND
YOU KNOW TO THREE MINUTE LONG.
THE DIFFERENT THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF DIFFERENT ONES BUT
PUTTING PROPRIETARY SCENARIOS ON
THOSE MACHINES IS COMPLICATED.
WE HAD TWO DEMONSTRATIONS FROM
VIRTUAL REALITY -- COMPANIES ON
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO AND
WHERE THEY'RE TRYING TO GO
THEY'RE NOT THERE YET WE HAD A
DEMO LASTS TWO WEEKS AGO.
SO WE DON'T WANT T GO IN AND
JUST SPEND THE MONEY ON
EQUIPMENT.
THE ONE IN SAN JOSE IT'S BEEN
THERE FOR THREE YEARS.
CORRECT AND I AND I BELIEVE SAN
JOSE'S IS A POST.
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT.
SO SO THAT IS THE THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE WE STAND WITH THE
EQUIPMENT.
I'M IN TERMS OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND DE ESCALATION WE HAD THE ONE
AT THE HOSPITAL VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER THE MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT PUT ONE TOGETHER. SIX
YEARS AGO [inaudible]
OKAY.
THOUGH THE SAME -- AND VERY
CANDIDLY THAN DONE I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF THE STUFF OUT
THERE ALREADY.
KIND OF LIKE YOU SAY YOU DON'T
HAVE.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN HAVE.
WELL WE HAVE THIRTY ONE I
BELIEVE THIRTY ONE MACHINE
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE READY.
WE WE ALSO CONTRACT OUT WITH
AGENCIES SUCH AS SAN JOSE PD TO
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THE TUNE OF
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THOSE MACHINES.
I ACTUALLY DID IT.
YEAH I MEAN IT'S GOOD VERY COULD
BE BETTER.
BUT ALSO ASSEMBLYMAN LOW SHOT
ENDED SO GOOD
WELL DILLON BROTHERS ALONG A
POLICE OFFICER.
TO IF IF IF IF I IF I CAN ALSO
ADDRESS THE FUNDING AND HOW WE
HAVEN'T REALLY SPENT IT'S A WIN
WIN FIRST ENGAGE WITH IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR IN THE
PART OF FINANCE.
WE WERE VERY VERY UP FRONT AND
SAID WE CANNOT SPEND THIS MONEY
OVER THE COURSE OF A YEAR
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE STARTING
FROM GROUND ZERO WE NEED MORE
TIME AND THAT'S WHY.
THE LEGISLATURE IN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ASKED FOR HALF
THE MONEY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I'M
GOING TO GET DOWN HERE.
YES FOR THE MONEY YOU ABLE TO DO
AND AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE NOT IT WILL SPEND THE
MONEY AND THEN.
YES.
FOR WE OT A LOT OF OTHER GROUPS
OF GOT TURNED DOWN FOR MONEY FOR
VARIOUS OTHER THINGS IN THE
BUDGET -- YOU KNOW -- WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR SOME LATER TODAY
THEY GOT TURNED DOWN.
SO I I KIND OF I KIND OF KNOW
THAT'S THAT'S THE POINT I'M
MAKING I MEAN.
THEN YOU HAVE ANOTHER REQUEST
HERE.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE POINT I'M
MAKING.
OF ARE YOU A CAN YOU GONNA TELLS
BUT THE MENTAL HEALTH.
SURE I WAS MY LEGISLATION.
SOON ARE.
YOU SEE THE NUMBER OF COURSES
ARE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT I
DID NOT BREAK THEM UP THERE
THEIR COMBINED ITS USE OF FORCE
DE ESCALATION MENTAL HEALTH BUT
IF I DID BREAK UP THE NUMBER OF
HOURS.
IF YOU SEE TWO HUNDRED AND
310-005-0020 EIGHT HOURS OF
TRAINING -- COURSE COMPLETIONS
ACTUAL COURSES IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
ABOUT 5152% OF THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY MENTAL HEALTH COURSES A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVEN OF THOSE
COURSE COMPLETIONS RELATE TO
MENTAL HEALTH TRAINING.
THE WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS TRêN NOW.
THESE ARE ALL POST OUR PERSONNEL
THAT ARE BEING TRAINED ON THIS.
OKAY.
YOUR OWN IDEA HOW MANY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT HELP BRING.
THE THIS ONLY INCLUDES COURSE
COMPLETIONS WE WE CAN PARSE IT
OUT INTO THE INDIVIDUAL NUMBER
OF STUDENTS BUT THAT WILL TAKE A
LITTLE BIT.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE TRAINED AT THIS POINT
[inaudible]
YEAH I'VE.
THAT WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT MORE
PARSING OUT OF THE DATA FROM THE
SYSTEM IT DOESN'T COME OUT THAT
WAY WHAT WE CAN TELL YOU IS
FORTY NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE OR
FORTY NINE THOUSAND COURSE
COMPLETIONS ARE HAPPENING EVERY
YEAR.
IN TERMS OF MENTAL HEALTH DE
ESCALATION AND USE OF FORCE
TRAINING IN CALIFORNIA HOURS A
BILL HELP TO HOMEOWNERS.
SO FOR THE BASIC ACADEMY IT'S
FIFTEEN HOURS AND THEN SOME OF
THE OTHER MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH
COURSES CAN RANGE FROM. FOUR
GENERALLY SPEAKING SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR HOURS I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY TO GO UP.
TO FORTY YOU THINK THAT'S ENOUGH
TRAINING.
I THINK SO.
I DO I BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE'S
ALSO TRAINING IN MINUTES
INCORPORATED INTO OTHER THINGS
LIKE THE FIELD TRAINING PROGRAM
WHICH DOESN'T CAPTURE ALL THE
STUFF BUT IS A NEW OFFICER.
WELL FEEL TRAINING FOR US IS
CONSIDERED TRAINING WE DON'T
CONSIDER THEM TO BE OFFICERS
THERE SPENDING SIX MONTHS.
GOING THROUGH A CURRICULUM AND
TRAINING CURRICULUM THAT WE
ESTABLISH ARM.
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE
SITTING IN A CAR WITH ANOTHER
OFFICER?
AND SOME OF THAT TOUCHES ON ON
DEALING WITH -- INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES.
RIGHT IT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN
THE BEGINNING THE FIRST RIVER
TRAINING IS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT.
THE CANDIDATE IS AN ACCEPTABLE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
SO AS PART OF THE PROCESS OF
MAKING SOME KIND OF
DETERMINATION.
WHETHER THEY CAN COMPLETE THE
TRAINING PROPERLY OR NOT.
DOES THE TRAINING INCLUDE THE
CULTURAL.
CONFIDENCE.
YES THERE IS A CULTURAL
DIVERSITY COMPONENT IN THE BASIC
ACADEMY I CAN'T YOU KNOW.
STILL AHEAD BUT IT IT THERE IS A
SEPARATE LEARNING DOMAIN ON
CULTURAL DIVERSITY INSIDE OF THE
ACADEMY INTERESTING GETTING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THAT WAS
IN THE STATURE IT WITH US -- SO --
THE THE FIND SPENT ON USE OF
FORCE HOW MUCH MONEY WAS SPENT
ON USE OF FORCE TRAINING.
SO UP UNTIL THIS YEAR USE OF
FORCE WE DID NOT.
WE DIDN'T FUNDED.
UNLESS IMPROVE THE USE OF FORCE
OF A THE AGENCY.
HOW TO USE OF FORCE COURSE?
DID YOU REVIEWER LOOK AT THE
COURSE WORK THAT THEY WERE
CLOSING -- EVERY USE OF FORCE
CORSET THAT IT'S IT WAS PROPOSED
TO POST.
WITH EITHER CERTIFIED OR NOT
CERTIFIED BY POST IT IF IT
DIDN'T MEET OUR PERISHABLE
SKILLS REQUIREMENTS.
THEN THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING
WAS NOT FUNDED BY POST THEY JUST
DID IT ON THEIR OWN.
I'M INTERESTED IN THEIR
STANDARDS FOR APPROVAL OR
DISAPPROVAL OF THE USE OF FORCE
TRAINING OKAY OF THEIR THERE.
IS CONTROVERSY ABOUT USE OF
FORCE TRAINING AND COURSES WE
KNOWN -- THE QUESTION WOULD BE
ARE WE ADEQUATELY REVIEWING --
USE OF FORCE TRAINING IN TERMS
OF THE PROPER USE OF FORCE
TRAINING AND NOT THERE'S CERTAIN.
TYPES OF USE OF FORCE
CONSULTANTS.
THE TRAIN -- OFFICERS
DIFFERENTLY THEY'RE HIRED BY.
POLICE AGENCIES.
TRAINED OFFICERS DIFFERENTLY
THAN OTHERS.
SO WE HAVE TO DISCERN DISCERN
WHETHER OR NOT THE COURSES.
THE CORRECT ONE WE WANT.
IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA'S LAWS
AND STATUTES.
OKAY AND AND I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT -- ISSUE FOR A A LOT
OF THE PUBLIC TO HAVE THE USE OF
FORCE TRAINING.
OF THE CERTIFIED.
IN TERMS OF THE CALIFORNIA LAWS
RATHER THAN HAVE OF THOSE PEOPLE
FROM ALL OVER.
THE COUNTRY TO COME IN HERE AND
THEY DO TRAINING IN THE I'VE
SEEN THE VARIOUS TRAINING PEOPLE --
THE NATIONAL POLICE THE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION TODAY CERTIFIED SOME
OF THESE TRAINING.
NOT THE NATIONAL POLICE CHIEFS
WHAT WHAT ORGANIZATIONS TO A
NATIONAL LEVEL.
REVIEW IS -- ON THE WAY YOU CAN
HAVE THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING
SWORD AT OUR CERTIFIED IN
CALIFORNIA BUT NATIONALLY AS A
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA TO TEACH
YOU SO NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
CERTIFYING.
WITH SOMEBODY HIRES A CONSULTANT.
DID YOU USE OF FORCE TRAINING.
IS WHAT HAPPENS THEY HIRED THE
POLICE ACADEMIES THE HIRE
SOMEBODY TO COME IN. TO PAY
MONEY. TO DO A USE OF FORCE
TRAINING.
THE CASH GOES TO THE CONSOLE.
OKAY AND THE QUESTION IS.
WHO ARE THESE CONSULTANTS AND
WEBER WHAT KIND OF TRAINING THEY
PROVIDING?
OUR POLICE OFFICERS.
YES SO THE QUESTION IS WHO'S
WHO'S LOOKING AT THESE
CONSULTANTS.
TRAINING MODULES WHO'S CHECKING
THEM OVER TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE IN CONFORMANCE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA LAWS.
OF EVERY OF THE FORTY ONE POLICE
ACADEMY WE HAVE TRAINING AND
TESTING SPECIFICATIONS THAT THEY
MUST ADHERE.
TO STUDENT WORKBOOK THAT WE
PROVIDE THEM.
WE REVIEW EVERY SINGLE COURSE
OUTLINE. TO THE THIRD LEVEL OF
DETAIL ON THE INSTRUCTION WE
REVIEW EVERY INSTRUCTOR RESUME
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
QUALIFIED TO TEACH AND THERE ARE
SOME MINIMUM STANDARDS THAT THEY
MUST ADHERE TO TO TEACH CERTAIN
PORTIONS OF THE ACADEMY.
AND I MUST GO THROUGH POLL POST
TRAINING.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
AT THE SAME TIME WE GO IN AND
AUDIT EVERY ACADEMY EVERY THREE
YEARS AT A MINIMUM THAT'S OUR
GOAL TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INSTRUCTIONS BEING DONE PROPERLY.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEARING TO CURRICULUM WE AUDIT
SOME OTHER COURSES.
PART OF THE B. C. P. ASKS FOR
MONEY FOR THAT PROGRAM THAT WAS
DE FUNDED.
I'M INTERESTED IN -- THE TYPES
OF TRAINING AND THAT YOU WOULD
FIND ACCEPTABLE.
VERSUS NON ACCEPTABLE.
THERE'S SOME THERE'S SOME
TRAININGS THAT -- NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE FOUND TO BE
UNACCEPTABLE -- I WANT TO FIND
OUT -- HOW WE DISCERN?
WHICH ONE IS WHICH AND WHICH
ONES ARE BEING PAID FOR BY.
OUR TAXPAYERS.
THERE ARE NO POLICE OFFICERS
THERE ARE NO OUTSIDE ENTITIES
ARE ALLOWED TO COME IN A TRAINER
POLICE ACADEMIES THEY'RE ALL
POSTS CERTIFY COURSES IN POST
CERTIFIED INSTRUCTORS OTHER --
PAID TO BE CONTROL OF IT THERE
ARE NO THERE ARE NO CONSULTANTS
THAT COME IN TO ANY LOCAL POLICE
ACADEMY IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
THAT TEACH OUTSIDE OF OUR POST
CURRICULUM.
REALLY GO OUT TO DO SO THEY'RE
PAID BY THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
NOW SIR COME IN AND TRAIN NOT
FOR THE POLICE ACADEMIES THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN WHICH
DEPARTMENTS.
WHICH DEPARTMENTS ARE ON THEIR
OWN IF THEY WANT POST FUNDING
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IF THEY WANT
TO BRING SOMEBODY IN TO TRAIN
THEM ON USE OF FORCE THAT'S UP
TO EACH INDIVIDUAL POLICE AGENCY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO FUNNY FROM
POST IT HAS TO BE POST CERTIFIED
TRAINING THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
DON'T REGULATE -- THOSE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THEY GO OFF ON THEIR
OWN AND ARE SOMEBODY THE TRAIN.
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
OR SHARE STUBBORN.
AT YOUR YOUR CORRECT SIR IN THE
IF IF THEY COME TO POST TO GET
POST CERTIFIED TRAINING.
ARE THERE TRAINING CERTIFIED
THEN WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW IT
WE'RE GONNA DO EVERYTHING YOU
JUST SAID TO MAKE SURE THE
INSTRUCTORS -- THE RIGHT
INSTRUCTORS THAT IT'S COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
AND THAT IS BEING DONE PROPERLY
THOUGH THEY DO IT HOWEVER OR
OUTSIDE AND DO IT OR GO AROUND
CLOSED IN OUR WAYS THERE'S
NOTHING.
HAPPENING BUT IT WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH.
THERE'S REXACH AYE TRAINING ON
HOW TO CATCH THAT I MEAN WHAT.
WAS THE PROCESS USED TO YOU KNOW
THEY COULD.
YOU SHOULD HAVE POST PEOPLE AND
I DO THE RIGHT THING AND THEN
YOU GO AROUND AND FIND OUT THEIR
TRAINING SOMEBODY COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
HELLO DEPARTMENT HAS THAT
ABILITY AND WE CAN'T WE DON'T
CONTROL THAT I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO
CONTROL THAT SO FOR DEPARTMENT
WANTS TO GO TO SOME PRIVATE
COMPANY AND QUE KANSAS CITY.
AND HAVE THEM COME TO CALIFORNIA
TO TEACH THEM.
IT'S EITHER GONNA BE POST
CERTIFIED OR IT'S NOT AND
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T GET IT POST
CERTIFIED IN YOU.
AND WE DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT
SOMETIMES GENERALLY SPEAKING
MOST OF THE TRAINING IT'S BEING
DONE IN CALIFORNIA IS POST
CERTIFIED.
ADMITTEDLY WITH SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE BUDGET REDUCTIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD.
THERE'S A DISINCENTIVE FOR THEM
TO GET OPPOSE CERTIFIED BECAUSE
WITH POST CERTIFICATION COMES
SOME SCRUTINY.
ON THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TRAINING IS PROPER THAT IT'S
GOOD AND THEN THEY HAVE SOME
BACKING FROM POST IF THEY GET
SUED.
AND THEN AND THEN THERE'S
FUNDING BEHIND BUT IF THERE'S NO
FUNDING AT TIMES.
THEN THEY DON'T COME TO US I
WANT TO KNOW WHY WOULD WHY WOULD
GIVE MONEY TO A POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND MAKE THEM CERTIFY THEIR
TRAINING FOR POST AND THEN HAVE
THEM GO AROUND US AND HAVE A NON
CERTIFIED TRAINING.
ON THE SAME SUBJECT.
OF OF TRAINING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENTLY.
RIGHT OF THE TABLE THAT'S THAT'S
THE ISSUE.
SO WE DON'T GIVE MONEY. TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS SO IF AND IF I MAY IF I
CAN YOU SEEN AS A POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE IDEA WE
REFER TO THEM IN A GREAT
DEPARTMENT I PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
USE THEM AS AN EXAMPLE.
BUT IF THEY DECIDE TO HAVE TO
USE A FORCED RATINGS AND THEY
BRING ONE TO POST FOR POST
CERTIFICATION.
WE'RE GOING TO SCRUTINIZE THAT
COURSE TO MAKE SURE IT'S COMPLY
IF IT'S WHATEVER IT IS WE'RE
GONNA MAKE A DECISION AS TO
WHETHER WE HAVE THE MONEY TO
FUND IT.
BUT SAME TIME SAN JOSE PD.
COULD GO. TO THE KANSAS CITY
PRIVATE PRESENTER AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO TWO
DIFFERENT COURSES AT RPD.
WE'RE GONNA DO OUR POST
CERTIFIED COURSE IT'S GONNA BE
FUNDED BY POST WE'RE GONNA PAY
FOR THIS ONE ON OUR OWN AND IT
AND IT'S JUST BETWEEN THEM.
THERE'S NO RULE THAT SAYS THAT
PRIVATE PERSON HAS TO BE.
CLEARED BY YOU OR ANY NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION IF THEY COME FOR
POST CERTIFICATION SO THAT THE
OFFICERS CAN GET CREDIT FOR
TAKING THAT COURSE THEY GET NO
CREDIT FOR TAKING THAT COURSE.
I'M NOW THEY DON'T COME TO US IN
ALL.
OF THE LITTLE CORRECT SIR.
OKAY MAN CHART KIND OF
INTERESTED IN THIS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE REALITY OF THE
TRAINING THAT GOES ON IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT SORT.
THANK YOU FOR THIS QUESTIONS --
I THINK WE NEED.
TO IT'S MORE ANSWERS ABOUT HOW
MUCH TRAINING.
IS DONE BY POLICE DEPARTMENTS
OUTSIDE OF THE POST CERTIFIED.
THAT'S WHERE THE I THINK MAYBE
THE PROBLEM.
THAT IS CLAYTON AND IF I MAY SIR
THAT IS GOING TO BE A VERY DIFF
IT'S HOW WE GONNA PROVE A
NEGATIVE I DON'T KNOW.
WHAT THOSE COURSES ARE WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING?
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
ALWAYS WE CANNOT TURN A BLIND
EYE TO IT THAT'S YOU CAN YOU
KNOW THAT'S NOT WAT WE'RE GONNA
DO WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT.
AND I I I I I SIDE ON THE ON THE
SIDE OF IT IT SEEMS LIKE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
GOING DOWN THE RIGHT PATH AND I
NOT BRING IN THESE.
CRAZY AND XIN COURSES THAT WE IS
COMMUNITY DO NOT WANT THEM TO
HAVE FOR WHAT I SEE MOST OF IT
IS POSITIVE.
POST CERTIFIED IF IT'S NOT
CLOSER TO FIGHT STILL GOOD
QUALITY TRAINING BUT THE
MAJORITY OF IT I THINK IS CLOSER
TO FIVE MY WORRY WOULD BE.
I'M JUST FISHERMEN -- I'M SORRY
IT TOOK SO LONG BUT MY WORRY IS
WE HAVE THESE POSTS CERTIFY YOUR
YOUR REGULATING THOSE ARE
CERTIFYING ON AND THEN SOMETHING
IS TRYING TO THE OFFICER THAT
COUNTERS.
WHAT THE POST TRAINING?
AND I THINK THERE'S A DANGER.
AND THAT HAPPENS POTENTIAL
DANGER WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
I DON'T CARE IF I CAN JUST.
SAY SOMETHING -- MOST AGENCIES
AND I USED TO WORK WITH SEVERAL
AGENCIES AS I WAS ALONG FORCING
CONSULTANT I WAS ASSIGNED TO
REGION ONE WHICH IS ALL WE HAVE
TO NORTHERN COASTLINE.
MOST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
HEADS.
WILL NOT SEND THE PEOPLE TO
TRAIN IF IT IS NOT POST
CERTIFIED IT'S NOT FINANCIALLY
PRUDENT FOR THEM TO DO SO
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT WE SET
THE STANDARD.
YOU KNOW THAT WE SET THE
CURRICULUM AND TO BRING IN
SOMEBODY FROM THE OUTSIDE THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO DO
THAT I THINK IT'S A LOT LESS
THAN WHAT YOU THINK IT IS.
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE BUT
I KNOW THAT I WAS WITH MY
AGENCIES.
ON A DAILY BASIS FOR FOUR YEARS
AND I KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK FOR
WHICH IS THE STANDARD THAT POST
SETS.
THE FUNDING THAT WE COULD
POSSIBLY PROVIDE TO THEM TO TO
TAKE THIS TRAINING.
SO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE ON
THE OUT LIARS.
I WOULD STICK TO THEIR VERY FEW
AND FAR BETWEEN.
RIGHT SO.
I THINK.
WELL.
BOTTOM LINE THE I'VE HEARD FROM
MANY OF OUR AGENCIES THAT --
THERE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THE
CUTS TO POST.
HAVE A REDUCE THE AMOUNT THEIR
ACCESS TO TRAINING AND SO
CLEARLY PART OF THE THE B. C. P.
AS AS DETAILED THE POST.
THE C. P..
RESTORE SOME OF THAT FUNDING.
WHICH WOULD YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S WHETHER IT'S ADEQUATE.
FOR THE THE LEVEL OF TRAINING
EITHER LEGISLATURE OR THE
AGENCIES WOULD WANT IN THE END
AND TO COVER ALL OFFICERS ARE
NOT -- I DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY
BEFORE US BUT CLEARLY I SEE THAT
THAT IS PART OF WHAT THE B. C.
P. ASTRIDE DESCRIBED.
THE THE REASON I RAISE THE
QUESTIONS IS. TO ME THAT'S THAT
IS A LEGITIMATE DISCUSSION.
BUT IS A DIFFERENT DISCUSSION
THEN THE FUNDING.
FOR EXPANDED OR ENHANCE TRAINING
ON THINGS LIKE USE OF FORCE AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH IN THE OTHER.
PRIORITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD AND SO WHAT I SAW ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND RATHER
IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET WAS THAT [inaudible]
MOVE TOWARDS.
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE MORE
DIRECTED TOWARDS IN FACT
ENHANCING OR IF NOT ENHANCING
MAKING ON GOING [inaudible]
THE NEW TRAINING A NEW
CURRICULUM THAT WAS DEVELOPED.
AS A RESULT OF THE ONE TIME ONLY
FUNDS.
AND SO I I THINK.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO ACT ON
THIS TODAY BUT I THINK THAT WHAT
WILL WANT.
WHEN WE COME BACK IS?
SOME DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THE
TWO AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT.
THE ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BE SPENT.
IN ONE YEAR BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE WE WANT YOU TO GET THE
RIGHT EQUIPMENT WE WANT YOU TO
DEVELOP A GOOD CURRICULUM.
IT WAS JUST VERY DISAPPOINTING
TO SEE THAT IT WAS ONLY THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND THAT HAD BEEN
SPENT AT LEAST WITH THE NUMBERS
THAT I WAS PROVIDED.
AND THEN TO SEE IN THE ON GOING
BC HE THAT FOR EXAMPLE.
UNDER THE TRAINING ENSURING
QUALITY THERE'S DEVELOP FOR
SCENARIOS IT'S ONLY HALF A
MILLION BUT IT'S DEVELOP FOR
SCENARIOS. FOR FORCE OPTION
SIMULATORS AND I'M THINKING OKAY --
IS NOT.
PART OF THE USE THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WHY IS IT NEED TO BE IN
THIS PCP.
OR FOR EXAMPLE IN THE SUPPORT
INCREASED WORKLOAD DEVELOP NEW
COURSE MATERIALS CERTAINLY YOU
MAY BE DEVELOPING NEW COURSE
MATERIALS IN SOME OTHER AREAS.
THAT'S OUR WOULDN'T POTENTIALLY
BE APPROPRIATE.
BUT IF FOR EXAMPLE AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR THIS WERE TO BE.
DEVELOPING NEW COURSE MATERIAL
PRIMARILY FOR THE USE OF FORCE.
OR THE OTHER MANDATES THAT WE
GAVE YOU FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
THEN IT WOULD SEEM THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN APPROPRIATE
EXPENDITURE IN THE ONE TIME ONLY
AND NOT IN THIS BCP.
OR THERE'S A COUPLE OF OTHERS
THAT YOU KNOW WE SO THAT'S WHAT.
WE'RE GONNA WANNA -- HAVE SOME
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHEN WE
WHEN WE ACTUALLY TAKE ACTION ON
THIS.
I'M.
BUT I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE LA --
BRIEFLY IF YOU CAN'T AND
ABSOLUTELY -- SO I NEED ONLY
WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING BEING
PROPOSED HERE IS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
ONGOING LEVEL FUNDING PROVIDED
TO POST.
SIR FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REALLY ENSURE
THAT WHATEVER FUNDING LEVEL
THAT'S PROVIDED AND WHATEVER
EXPENDITURE PLAN REALLY REFLECTS
PRIORITY.
THE PLAN THAT POST AS PUT
FORWARD IS DEFINITELY ONE
APPROACH -- TO PROVIDE THAT
TRAINING BECAUSE THEY'VE CLEARLY
EVALUATED ALL OF THE PROGRAM'S
EXETER AND CAME UP WITH THIS
PLAN.
THAT BEING SAID THE LEGISLATURE
IN RECENT YEARS HAS GONE DOWN
THE PATH OF EXPRESSING SPECIFIC
EXPECTATIONS AND PRIORITIES AND
SO THEY COULD CHOOSE TO DO SO
AGAIN PARTICULARLY SINCE THIS
AND THEN IT THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT ONGOING DOLLARS
THAT'S REALLY SIGNIFICANT.
SO THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING POST REPORT
ANNUALLY ON SPECIFIC OUTCOME IN
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT ARE
TIED TO WHATEVER FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED.
AND THIS WILL REALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE MONITOR THE USE OF
THOSE DOLLARS AND EVALUATE HOW
THE FUNDING IS USED.
AND ALSO TO HELP THEM MAKE
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE LEGISLATURE --
pFUNDING IN THE FUTURE OR CHANGE
THE MIX THAT SORT OF REPORTING
WOULD HELP THEM WITH THEIR
DECISION MAKING.
THANK YOU.
I'M IN JUST A COUPLE OF OTHER
POINTS -- SENATOR BILL RAISE
SOME OF THE ISSUES AROUND.
THE QUALITY AND HE RAISED.
ME MUCH OF THE QUESTIONS WERE IN
MORE IN THE POTENTIAL
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE QUALITY
OF TRAINING IS THAT A DEPARTMENT
MIGHT PURSUE THAT OUR POST
CERTIFIED.
BUT I THINK ADDITIONALLY.
THERE'S BEEN.
SOME INDICATION BY SOME AGENCIES
THAT THERE'S A OUR ONE USE WIDE
CASSETTE.
YOU KNOW ANECDOTAL INFORMATION
IS NOT REALLY ACCURATE TIP BUT
THERE'S A A VARIANCE IN THE
QUALITY EVEN OF THE POST
TRAININGS [inaudible]
AND SO ONE QUESTION WOULD BE HOW
IS POST CURRENTLY ASSESSING THAT
QUALITY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
MORE ASSURANCE THAT THERE'S HIGH
LEVEL QUALITY AMONGST ALL OF
THOSE.
AND WHAT IS IN PLACE TO ASSESS
WHETHER THOSE TRAININGS ACTIVE
OR NOT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I'M.
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE USED TO HAVE
A QUALITY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM.
RATHER ROBUST ONE THAT WE HAD TO
REDUCE ARE ACTUALLY -- GET RID
OF BECAUSE OF THE DWINDLING
BUDGET AND ONE THING IN THE B.
C. P. THAT WE PUT IN WAS TO
AUGMENT THAT BY A MILLION
DOLLARS TO ACTUALLY DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WHICH IS.
GO OUT AND ACTUALLY STAND THERE
AND WATCH THE TRAINING TO ENSURE
THE FACT THESE THE QUALITY IS
THE SAME THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THAT'S ONE OF OUR OUR BIG
TARGETS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS WITH OUR
WITH OUR BUDGET.
AM WE'VE GONE FROM A HUNDRED
THIRTY SOMETHING INDIVIDUALS OUT.
TO ONE EIGHTEEN EN WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO DO AND WE HAVE A VERY
ROBUST PROGRAM IN PLACE ON HOW
WE WILL EXPAND THIS MONEY.
WHICH IS IN -- WE EVEN INTO THE
THE PAPERWORK THEM THAT WE
PROVIDE YOU AND ALSO MANAGE
TESTIMONY.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE THE WAY WE
ENVISION THIS IS YOU'RE NOT JUST
HAVE STANDALONE COURSES FOR
THESE PARTICULAR PROCEDURE
JUSTICE THE ESCALATION MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BUT TO INTEGRATE
THEM INTO EVERY PORTION OF POST
TRAINING FROM THE TIME THAT THEY
GO TO THE ACADEMY TO THE TIME
THEY'RE AN EXECUTIVE.
THAT TO ME IS GOING TO TURN OUT
A MORE A BETTER WELL ROUNDED
INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE DECISIONS THE
MATURITY LEVEL -- THIS IS
EXACTLY THE PROGRAM THAT WE WANT
TO PUT FORWARD TO YOU IN THE B.
C. P. THAT MAY NOT BE OUTLINED
AS MUCH AS YOU HAVE SEEN BUT WE
HAVE -- IS GOING TO TURN OUT
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING.
FOR AND THAT'S THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE FOR ME.
IF IF I MAY ADD ON TO A WITNESS
SANDOVAL SAID.
MADAM CHAIR SO EVERY.
LIVING [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT YOU DESCRIBED IS THAT
[inaudible]
THE ASSESSMENTS.
AND AGAIN NOT TO JUST JUMP TO A
CONCLUSION BUT WITHOUT HAVING
YOU GIVE MORE EXPLANATION I GOT
ASSUME THERE'S NO QUALITY
ASSESSMENT GOING ON RIGHT NOW IS
THAT THE CASE.
THAT IS CORRECT THERE'S NOBODY
RECESSED MOTION OF THAT THERE
THE QUALITY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM.
HAS NOT BEEN FUNDED AT POST.
THERE IS QUALITY ASSESSMENT WITH
THE TRAINING MANAGERS THROUGHOUT
THE REGIONS THROUGHOUT THEIR OWN
TRAINING PROGRAMS.
BUT AS FAR AS A SENDING
INDIVIDUALS.
TO OUTSIDE OF JUST THE REGULAR --
COURSES WE DO MONITOR THE POLICE
ACADEMIES.
WE DO MONITOR OUR LEGACY COURSES
BUT EACH INDIVIDUAL AGENCY
THERE'S OVER. 400-040-00300
COURSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO KEEP A
TIGHT CLOSE LID ON THEM AS MUCH
AS WE WOULD LIKE TO BECAUSE OF
THE DWINDLING RESOURCES AND AND
FINANCIAL.
IMPACT POST.
IF I CAN ADD MADAM CHAIR EVERY
COURSE THERE'S A SURVEY THAT'S
DONE EITHER FOR THE ONLINE
COURSES OR THE AND PERSON
COURSES THAT WE REVIEW.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA SLI
IS ONE OF OUR FOUNDATIONAL
INSTRUCTION COURSES IT COSTS A
LOT OF MONEY IT'S EIGHT MONTHS
OF TRAINING FOR IT SERGEANTS.
ARM.
JUST REVIEWING THOSE OUTLINES WE
PICKED UP ON A VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM LAST YEAR.
BUT THE OUTLINES BY REVIEWING
THOSE SUMMARIES WE GOT RID OF
WELL WE GOT RID OF A PERSON WAS.
I'M NOT ALLOWED TO DO ANYMORE
SLI TRAINING FORCE BASED ON SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE WERE
FINDING.
SO WE ARE REVIEWING ALL THE
SURVEYS.
THEY'RE BEING DONE AFTER THE
COURSE IS COMPLETE AND A WHAT
MISS SANDOVAL SAID IS CORRECT IS
IF IF THERE IS AN ISSUE THAT WE
START HEARING ABOUT WHERE WE HAD
INDEPENDENT PEOPLE TO GO OUT AND
I DID SOME OF THESE COURSES OR
WHEN WE SEE THAT THEIR SMOKE
COMING.
IN A CERTAIN DIRECTION WE COULD
SEND PEOPLE WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ABILITY BUT WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
AN ABILITY ANYMORE BUT WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS.
WE DO SAID POST STAFF JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA WE SUPPOSE
STAFF MEMBER. TWO MONTHS AGO. TO
COME OFF LINE TO GO SIT ON A
COURSE WHERE WE HAD HEARD
RUMBLINGS.
THAT THE INSTRUCTOR THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE TEACHING THE
COURSE WASN'T THE INSTRUCTOR
[inaudible]
IT WASN'T.
IT WASN'T THE INSTRUCTOR THAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE LISTED THAT
THEY WERE SELLING THEIR WARES
FROM THEIR PRIVATE COMPANY YOU
KNOW FOR THE FIRST X. AMOUNT OF
MINUTES.
THAT THEIR T. SHIRTS IN THE BACK
YOU KNOW MARKETING THEIR COMPANY.
SO WE TOOK HIM OFF LINE.
BUT THAT WAS ONE INDIVIDUAL
STAFF MEMBER THAT HAD TO GO DO
THAT WHEN WE HEARD OF A PROBLEM.
SO WE DO WANT TO DO MORE OF THAT
AND THE OTHER THING NOT JUST
WHEN THERE'S PROBLEMS WE WANT TO
KNOW THAT OUR TRAINING IS GOOD
QUALITY TRAINING AND THAT'S WHAT
WE PUT INTO THE B. C. P. WE WANT
PEOPLE. TO GO IN AND LOOK AT
FIVE OF OUR DE ESCALATION
COURSES AND TELL US WHAT'S WRONG
WITH THEM NOT JUST TO TELL US
WHETHER THE PERSON SELLING.
CHALLENGE COINS DURING THEIR YOU
KNOW THEIR PRESENTATION.
BUT ARM IT'S A CHALLENGE RIGHT
NOW IS MISS SANDOVAL POINTED BUT
WE DO GET WE DO ASK FOR
RESPONSES FOR EVERY COURSE.
COMPLETION.
I'M GIVING YOUR REFERENCE.
TO I'M THERE IS.
IN THE B. C. P. THE FOURSOME
LATER -- THAT I MENTIONED -- I
KNOW THAT THAT IS ONE OF THE THE
VIRTUES.
THAT.
TYPE OF EQUIPMENT WHICH IS A
VIRTUAL REALITY EQUIPMENT.
IS ONE OF THE WAYS THAT -- USE
OF FORCES TRAINED ON SO THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS.
WHO IS MAKING BE -- WHO?
WHO ARE USING TO MAKE THE
ASSESSMENT OF WHETHER?
IT IS THE BEST TRAINING APPROACH.
AND WHETHER THE EQUIPMENT THAT
EITHER YOU HAVE -- YOU MIGHT
WANT TO BE. TO BE ACQUIRING.
IS THE BEST APPROACH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
NO IT.
I BELIEVE IT'S A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH WITH THE SIMULATORS --
SO.
ONE THE EQUIPMENT HAS TO BE GOOD
EQUIPMENT RIGHT I DON'T THINK
VIRTUAL REALITY EQUIPMENT IS
NECESSARILY WORDS SHOULD BE.
THE FOR SUCTION SIMULATORS ARE
GOOD BUT THE SCENARIOS.
ARE PROBABLY WHAT WE ALL WOULD
LIKE.
INTO ITS INSTRUCTOR IT'S IT'S
PUSHING THE BUTTON ON THE
MACHINE TO PROVIDE PROPER
INSTRUCTION AND FEEDBACK IN
TERMS OF COVER AND CONCEALMENT
DID YOU CONSIDER THIS DID YOU
CONSIDER THAT OR THEY JUST HIT
PLAY ON THE MACHINE.
AND GOOD YOU DID A GOOD JOB AND
WALK OUT SO IT'S A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH.
WE HAVE AN INSTRUCTOR COURSE FOR
THOSE SIMULATORS ARM.
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE HAS BEEN
FUNDED -- BUT IT'S THERE I THINK
WE TRAINED.
IN A COUPLE HUNDRED OFFICERS A
YEAR ON THAT COURSE.
BUT IT'S ALL OF THAT THAT MAKES
IT WORK PROPERLY.
SO PART OF MY QUESTION IS SO ARE
WE SO WHAT I'M UNDERSTAND FROM
WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING IS THAT.
IT IS INTERNAL POST STAFF.
THAT WOULD BE DOING THOSE
ASSESSMENTS [inaudible]
I'M.
AND I'M NOT THE NO JUDGMENT ON
THIS NO NO OPINION ON IT BUT
VERSUS SAY AN EXTERNAL.
ENTITY THAT YOU MIGHT.
CONTRACT WITH OR SOMETHING SO
IT'S INTERNAL POST STAFF THAT DO
BOTH THE ASSESSMENTS INSTRUCTOR
IN SUCH.
SEC BRECHT RIGHT WE HAVE.
ONE GOING ALONG WITH -- SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS.
SO WE ONCE WE CAN TRY AND NARROW
THINGS DOWN TO CERTAIN VENDORS.
WE WILL BRING IN INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO COME IN
AND LOOK AT IT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE FIELD.
DOING THE JOB CURRENTLY AS WELL
AS OUR POST STAFF. ONE OF THE
THINGS HE SAW THAT YOU MENTION
ABOUT THE FORCE OFTEN SIMILAR
SCENARIOS WE WANT TO DO FOR HIS
NEW SCENARIOS A YEAR WITH THE
ABILITY TO HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL
MAKE A DECISION.
AND I THEY MAKE ONE DECISION
THEY'RE THEY'RE TAKING DOWN ONE
PATH OF MAKE A DECISION OTHER
DECISION ARE TAKING ON DIFFERENT
PATHS.
FIRST IS -- WHAT SENATOR BILL
JUST WENT THROUGH WHICH WAS A
SHOOT DON'T SHOOT?
THOSE DON'T DO A WHOLE LOT FOR
DECISION MAKING PROCESSES AND
DEVELOPING MATURITY ON THE HAVE
A ON BEHALF OF THE POLICE
OFFICER.
SO IT'S KIND OF INTERNAL AS WELL
AS IT WILL BE EXTERNAL BECAUSE
WE DO NEED.
OUR EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS TO
HAVE BY AND AND AND GIVE US THAT
THE CURRENT PRACTICES.
NOBODY I THINK AGAIN.
GIVEN THE LEGISLATURE'S
DIRECTION.
IN TERMS OF THE WHILE.
WELL THERE WAS NOT [inaudible]
ON A POLICY DIRECTIVE AS TO WHAT
THE WHAT AM I A S. HOW DO I
COMMUNICATE THIS THAT.
WELL THERE WASN'T A A POLICY
DIRECTIVE IN ALL RIGHT HERE IS
WHAT THE OF FLOOR.
FOR USE OF FORCE INDIA
ESCALATION TRAINING SHOULD BE.
THE THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION WAS
MORE [inaudible]
TOWARD JUST.
IMPROVE AN INCREASE AND FOCUS ON
IT [inaudible]
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THOSE THINGS
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE BEFORE WE
PROCEED WITH.
THE NEW SCENARIOS [inaudible]
RIGHT THOSE.
SO.
I THINK THE THE MISSING
COMPONENT WITH IT IS THE
EQUIPMENT AT THIS BY RIGHT SO
THE SCENARIOS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE STANDARDIZED POSTED AREAS WE
TRAIN.
THE INSTRUCTORS ON THOSE POSTING
AREAS AND HOW THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO USE THE MACHINES AND WHAT
TOPICS ARE SUPPOSED TO HEAR WHAT.
AREAS ARE SUPPOSED YES BUT WE'VE
JUST GIVEN YOU WE'VE GIVEN YOU A
NEW DIRECTOR OF AGAIN WITHOUT.
A LOT OF DETAIL REGARDING YOU
KNOW WHAT MODIFICATIONS IN
POLICY THERE MIGHT BE.
BUT THAT MIGHT THEN INFORM.
WHAT THE SCENARIOS ARE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE THE SCENARIOS IN PLACE WELL
WE SHOULD HAVE THE THE HE RIVER.
REVAMPS NEW ENHANCE RIVER
CURRICULUMS.
IN PLACE.
THAT WOULD HELP THEN INFORM THE
WITH THOSE SCENARIOS ARE IF
GIVEN AGAIN THAT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. ONE TIME ONLY WAS NOT
JUST FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY.
IT WAS FOR ENHANCING POSTS
ABILITY TO DO TRAINING REGARDING
USE OF COURSE.
ANTI ESCALATION AND I'M SURE
THERE IS A COUPLE OF THE THINGS
I DON'T HAVE THE LANGUAGE.
DIRECTLY BEFORE BY.
THOSE -- THOSE SIMULATORS ARE.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THEY ARE
USED.
FOR YEAH ONE PART NOT THE ONLY.
YEAH.
SO IT'S KIND OF THE POINT I'M
MAKING.
THE ONLY OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
IS.
AND AGAIN YOU DON'T HAVE A
CRYSTAL BALL YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL DO BUT WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS BEFORE
US.
THAT COULD -- COULD.
WEIGH IN ON WHAT EITHER ON SOME
FOCUSES ON TRAINING OR SOME
CHANGES IN USE OF FORCE RULES.
I WHAT ARE YOU DOING NOW.
I SUPPOSE IN ANTICIPATION OF
THAT SO THAT YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO RE CREATE
TRAINING LATER.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE NOT TAKING A
POSITION ON EITHER OF COURSE NOT
EITHER BILL -- YOU KNOW.
I THINK WE'RE IN A POSITION WE
HAVE PLENTY OF USE OF FORCE --
OF A FOUNDATION ON USE OF FORCE
TRAINING PRIMARILY FROM THE
BASIC ACADEMY.
THE WE WILL INCORPORATE INTO
WHATEVER COMES OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED YOUR DOESN'T
SIGN I THINK WE'LL BE IN A IN A
GOOD POSITION SO.
ADMITTEDLY WERE WAITING TO SEE
WHAT -- WHAT ULTIMATELY
TRANSPIRES BUT WE FEEL LIKE?
WHICHEVER WAY GOES WILL BE READY --
IN TERMS OF THE EQUIPMENT IS
GOING BACK TO THE FIRST PART --
WE'RE COMMITTED TO PURCHASING
NEW NEW SIMULATORS AND MAYBE
THAT WILL DRIVE.
YOU KNOW THAT'LL BE THAT THE
CARD THAT DRIVES THE HORSE BY
GETTING THE NEW SIMULATORS IN
THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR -- BUT I
THINK WE CAN MAKE IT ALL HAPPEN
WE ALREADY HAVE THE
INSTRUCTIONAL PIECE WE ALREADY
HAVE THE X..
THE EXPERTISE SO TO SPEAK WITH
THE MACHINES ARM WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE GET THE THE RIGHT
EQUIPMENT WE DON'T WANT THEM.
ALWAYS THE MONEY [inaudible]
AND OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUE ENTER MORE LACK.
QUESTION FOR A MISLI -- ON ON
THE REPORT WE HAVE FIVE PAGE.
SEVEN OUT WE'RE STILL USING
PARENTHESES AROUND SUB TOTALS
AND OF BEING AN ACCOUNTANT
THAT'S REALLY IRRITATING TO ME
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WILL THE
NEW.
LA OF CHANGE THE FORMAT THE
JUSTIN UNDERLINE IT AND THEN A
DOUBLE UNDERLINED FOR THE TOTAL
LIKE IN MOST ACCOUNTANTS DO OR
WE'RE GONNA STAY WITH THE SYSTEM --
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY
CAN BE DISCUSSED WITH THE NEW
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
IN OUR SCHEDULE APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME -- WE'RE GONNA
HOLD IT OPEN.
AND APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
AND CLEARLY YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
CONCERNS.
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AWESOME ALL RIGHT
MANAGER THANK YOU -- WE ARE NOW --
I THINK WE'RE GONNA RETURN TO
THE FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA SIX
NINETY ISSUE ONE ISSUE -- TWO WE
ARE HOPING TO TAKE ACTION ON
THOSE BUT CERTAINLY -- THE
MEMBERS MIGHT HAVE.
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE ENTERTAIN A
VOTE ON ON THEY ARE THE FEDERAL
FIND.
AUGMENTATION.
FOR THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
ALL RIGHTS FOR THE HAZARD
MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM
[inaudible]
ON AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE REQUEST
THAT'S ISSUE.
TO WE CAN DO A MESS TO DIFFERENT --
WE HAVE TO TWO DIFFERENT MOTION
SIR GREEN MOVEMENTS.
ONE I THINK WE COULD MOVE MESS --
ONE YEAH.
OKAY SO WE HAVE MOTION ON BOTH
THOSE ITEMS THERE WERE -- WE
OBVIOUSLY WILL GET TO LOOK AT
OUR THE LANGUAGE IN -- THE
APPROVAL IN CASE WE WANT TO ADD --
ON THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IF
WE WANT TO AND END UP ADDING
REPORTING LANGUAGE I DON'T THINK
WE NEED TO SPECIFY THAT IN THIS
MOTION BUT WE CAN ALWAYS.
DISCUSS THAT IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE BILL.
BUT SO WILL -- WE HAVE A MOTION
NOW WILL DO A ROLL CALL IN THIS
IS ON APPROVING.
ISSUE ONE ISSUE TWO IS BUDGET.
CENTER SKINNER HI UNDER MORE
LOCK.
SENATE ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE WILL MOVE.
TO ON THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES EVEN THOUGH
THOSE WERE ITEMS ON THAT BUT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD ISSUE.
FOR AND THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL.
ITEM ON THE CONSOLIDATION OF
VICTIM SERVICES.
SO I'M ACTUALLY GONNA OPEN THIS
ONE OUT FOR EVERYONE I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M.
MANAGING WORTH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M GOING
TO GIVE LIKE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
FOR EVERYONE AND THEN I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO THE DEPARTMENTS TO
TALK MORE ABOUT THE REPORT
ITSELF.
I CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL
LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
VICTIMS PROGRAMS AND MANY STE IN
MANY STATES THAT WANT TO EMULATE.
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVED A LARGE
INFLUX OF FEDERAL DOLLARS OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS THE HELP
SUPPORT MORE THAN EIGHTY VICTIMS
SERVICES PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE OLDEST AND
SECOND LARGEST VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION.
I THINK WE AS A STAY ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THE BEST
POSSIBLE SERVICE FOR VICTIMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THERE HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION RECENTLY THAT SHOWS
THE LEGISLATURE'S AS WELL AS THE
MINISTRATIONS CONTINUED
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING VICTIMS.
AB TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR A
BUDGET BUDGET TRAILER BILL FROM
LAST YEAR -- PROVIDES VICTIMS
AND THE FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF
THE GOLDEN STATE COLOR.
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
COMPENSATION YEARS PAST THE
THREE YEAR DEADLINE TO TO THE
ARREST OF THE SUSPECT IN THE
CASE.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES
VZV OR THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD TO USE THE INTEGRATED
TRAUMA RECOVERY SERVICES MODEL
THAT WAS DEVELOPED BY THE SAN
FRANCISCO TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER.
WHEN IT PROVIDES GRANTS TO TRY
TO TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTERS I
THINK THIS MODEL IS SEEN AS A
BEST PRACTICES MODEL IN THE
STATE?
ANOTHER ONE WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY IS AS
THE EIGHT FORTY WHICH IS LAST
YEAR'S.
BUDGET BILL SB EIGHT FORTY PER
INCLUDED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD AND THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO
DEVELOP OPTIONS AND A
RECOMMENDATION FOR COMBINING THE
VICTIMS ESTATES VICTIMS PROGRAMS.
I THINK THERE ARE MANY
COMPONENTS TO THE OPTIONS AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WILL BE
DISCUSSED AND I TINK WE NEED TO
EXERCISE CAUTION.
SO WE CAN MAKE A WELL INFORMED
DECISION.
I'M THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
UNDER CONSIDERATION WITHIN THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND WHILE THE
WORKING GROUP RECOMMENDED A TWO
TO THREE YEAR CONSOLIDATION.
WE ARE ALREADY MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS ON SHARING INFORMATION
AND COLLABORATING COLLABORATING
ON VICTIMS ISSUES.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS VERY
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT THEM.
SO WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON THIS TOPIC IN MORE DETAIL IN
THE COMING MONTHS -- WITHOUT
ALTERNATE OVER -- TO YES NBC
PEAS SO THEY CAN ELABORATE ON
THE WORKING GROUP EFFORTS THE
PROCESS AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE REPORT.
REMEMBER YOU START I THINK WHAT --
ALL NOTE FOR MY COLLEAGUES IS
THAT.
THE ITEM INDICATES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN WAS TO
COME BACK TO US WITH REPORT ON
THIS CONSOLIDATION IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY NINETEEN SO THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
AND WE WOULD OBVIOUSLY THEN I
MEAN IF WE HAVE -- FROM HEARING
TODAY IF WE HAVE SOME ISSUES
WITH THE DIRECTION WE OF COURSE
CAN.
A COMMONER INVOLVE OURSELVES BUT
OTHERWISE WE WOULD HAVE THE
REPORT IN DECEMBER AND THUS NEXT
YEAR WE WOULD BE ABLE.
TO HAVE A HEARING.
YOU KNOW HOW INCLUDE IT IN A
HEARING AND BE ABLE TO GET INTO
MORE DETAIL AROUND WHETHER WE
WOULD WHETHER WE AGREE WITH THAT.
WASTE THAT THE TWO ENTITIES
CONSOLIDATED THEIR SERVICES OR
NOT BUT WE AT LEAST WILL CAN
HEAR SOME MORE ABOUT WHAT THEY
PLANNED BUT WILL GET THE REPORT
IN DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
CORRECT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THIS IS
JUST THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
WORKING GROUP -- I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TOLD STILL
TAKING A DEEP DIVE INTO WHAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AND I WILL
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH
YOU GUYS THROUGHOUT THE REST THE
SPRING.
EARLY BUT WE WILL GET A REPORT
DECEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN IT IS A
RECOMMENDATION FROMTHEM -- FROM
THE WORKING GROUP AND SO WE ARE
WORKING AS ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH THEM -- TO WORK ON OF A
PLAN.
WE HOPE TO GET A REPORT IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
YOU MAY ERCENT SURE I'LL
INTRODUCE MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUE INTRODUCED HERSELF I'M
JULIE NAM AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE --
OFFICER THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD.
GOOD GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GRACE COKE I AM THE CHIEF DEPUTY
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SO WE AGREE WERE JUST CONCURRENT
SURE OF THE TIME HERE WITH YOU --
AND FOLLOWING UP ON THE COMMENTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE I
JUST GIVE YOU JUST A FEW PIECES
OF INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THIS
REPORT CAME ABOUT.
BEING DEVELOPED AS A RESULT OF
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WHO
PARTICIPATED THE METHODOLOGY WE
USED TO DEVELOP IT.
AND THEN GRACE WILL REVIEW WITH
YOU ARE THE PRIMARY
RECOMMENDATION COMING OUT OF THE
AYE REPORT AND SOME
COLLABORATIVE WORK WE'VE BEEN
DOING SINCE THAT TIME.
SO IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
PASSAGE OF THE BUDGET -- WE
ASSEMBLED A WORKING GROUP
CONSISTING OF THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND THE VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD AND WE MET REGULARLY OVER
THE COURSE OF SEVERAL WEEKS
DEVELOPING THE METHODOLOGY FOR
THIS AM STUDY -- WE ENGAGED OUR
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE IS IT'S NOT
A NEW ISSUE IT'S PAN LOOKED AT
MANY TIMES OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
STAKEHOLDERS SO IT WAS CRITICAL
TO US TO BUILD IN A STAKEHOLDER.
ENGAGEMENT INTO THE PROCESS SIR
WE ADMINISTERED A SURVEY -- TO
OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED I'M
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ASKING THEM A SERIES
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR
REACTIONS TO A POTENTIAL A
CONSOLIDATION OF THESE SERVICES
FROM THESE TWO STATE ENTITIES.
ARM IN ADDITION WE HELD -- THREE
FORMS FOR STAKEHOLDERS --
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ONE IN
SACRAMENTO WHEN IN OAKLAND ONE
LOS ANGELES IN LATE AUGUST AND
EARLY SEPTEMBER ALSO -- TO
PRESENT SOME IDEAS THAT WE WERE
THINKING ABOUT AS WE WERE
PULLING THE REPORT TOGETHER AND
GETTING THEIR THEIR FEEDBACK.
WE ALSO CONSULTED WITH OTHER
STATES -- BOTHOF OUR PROGRAMS
ARE PROGRAMS THAT EXIST.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY -- VIEWS THAT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND THE
COMPENSATION PROGRAM.
SOME STATES ORGANIZE THEM THOSE
TWO PROGRAMS DIFFERENTLY THAN WE
DO AND WE CONSULTED WITH A
VARIETY OF STATES INCLUDING NEW
YORK PENNSYLVANIA SOUTH CAROLINA
AND THE STATE OF WASHINGTON. TO
LEARN FROM THEIR EXPERIENCE OF
LOOKING A CONSOLIDATION AND WHAT
THE PROPOSED WHETHER IT WAS AN
ACTIVE BUT IF THEY FELT THAT AT
THAT CONSOLIDATION WAS --
IMPROVEMENT AND MORE EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DELIVER SERVICES IN THEIR
STATE.
SO WE ADAM WENT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS -- TO INSURE THAT WE
WERE AND TESTING OF THIS CONCEPT
WITH OTHERS WHO HAD DONE SO IN
THE PAST.
SO THOSE WERE THE THE THE WITH
THOSE ARE THE WAYS THAT WE WENT
ABOUT -- DEVELOPING THIS YOU'LL
YOU NOTED IN THE STUDY WE ALSO
GIVE YOU A A DISCUSSION OF THE
MANY.
PREVIOUS AT AS STUDIES AND
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE ON
THIS TOPIC SO TAKING OFF OF
THOSE WITHIN CONSULTED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND ULTIMATELY.
CAME UP WITH A NUMBER OF OPTIONS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ALTERNATIVE
RIGOROUS.
WELL SURE BUT JUST BRIEFLY
DISTURB SOME CONTEXT FOR THE
RULES RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR
OFFICES AS A VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD PROVIDES
DIRECT COMPENSATION TO VICTIMS.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR VICTIMS
SERVICES PROVIDE FUNDING AND
SERVICES. TO DIRECT -- TO THOSE
WHO PERFORM DIRECT SERVICES TO
VICTIMS SO WE SUPPORT THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THE VICTIMS.
SO THERE'S THERE'S TO A UNIQUE --
ASPECTS TO TO THIS COORDINATED
ROLE -- SO WE HAD MINISTER THOSE
PROGRAMS.
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS WE AS WAS
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COLLABORATION AND STAKEHOLDER
INPUT.
OF THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES HAS ESTABLISHED FIVE
ADVISORY COMMITTEES. TO INFORM
AND HELP IDENTIFY THE GAPS IN
FUNDING AND SERVICES SO WE USE
OF STAKE HOLDERS MULTI
DISCIPLINE GROUPS TO HELP INFORM
THOSE GAPS.
AND THOSE -- THERE'S FIVE FIVE
AND COMMITTEES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THE A REPORT ON
AND AS WELL ASAS WAS MENTIONED
THE INCREASE OF FUNDING.
RIGHT RECOGNIZING THE NEED TO
MAXIMIZE AND LEVERAGE THE
FUNDING FROM THE VICTIMS OF
POINT OF VIEW.
SO -- WE ARE WE ARE SENATORS
FIVE OF THE SIX MAIN FORMULA
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR VICTIMS
SERVICES INCLUDING THE VICTIMS
OF CRIME ACT ASSISTANCE FORMULA
GRANT PROGRAM.
SERVICES TRAINING OFFICERS
PROSECUTION STOP VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN FORMULA GRANT
PROGRAM SEXUAL ASSAULT SERVICES
FORMULA PROGRAM CHILD JUSTICE
ACT GRANTS TO STATE PROGRAMS AND
FAMILY VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES.
GRANTS TO STATES FOR DEVELOPMENT
THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS AND
SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM.
SO WE'VE ESTABLISHED
APPROXIMATELY AT EIGHTY SIX
DIFFERENT VICTIM SERVICES AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAMS AND HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENCE OF RECIPIENTS.
THAT ARE DELIVERING THOSE DIRECT
SERVICES TO VICTIMS THROUGHOUT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AS WELL
AS TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AND THE TRAINING PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED TO BETTER EQUIPPED AND
PREPARE FIRST RESPONDERS -- AND
THOSE SERVICE PROVIDERS TO WORK
WITH VICTIMS OF CRIME AND
IMPROVE THEIR RESPONSE.
AND THERE'S ALSO A DIVERSITY OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
REACH SOME OF THE UNDER
REPRESENTED.
A POPULATIONS GROUPS -- OVER TWO
HUNDRED THE RECIPIENTS ARE
PROVIDING -- THOSE SERVICES.
TO A NON PROFITS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
SURROUNDING SUPPORT TO A VARIETY
OF OF DIVERSE PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
SO.
WITH OVER MORE THAN 56% OF
VICTIMS BEING UNDER OUR NON
REPORTED.
IT ONE OF THE PIVOTAL
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE VICTIMS CAN ACCESS A VARIETY
OF TRAUMA INFORMED VICTIM
CENTERED SERVICE IN A SETTING
THAT IS COMFORTABLE FOR THEM.
SO THAT THEY ARE COMFORTABLE IN.
IN REPORTING AND GETTING SUPPORT
FROM THOSE THAT CAN HELP THEM
AND ARE EQUIPPED TO HELP THEM
AND RECOVER FROM FROM THOSE
THOSE CRIMES.
AND SO THROUGH THIS PROCESS WE
HAVE BEEN COLLABORATING WITH OUR
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PARTNERS AS
WELL AS SOME OF OUR OTHER STATE
AGENCY PARTNERS.
THAT -- THAT ALSO HAVE SERVICES
FOR THE VICTIMS OR THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO IN THE REPORT THERE WERE A
FEW OPTIONS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
THAT REALLY TOOK A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT APPROACHES WHEN WAS
WAS.
DOING NOTHING WAS NOT AN OPTION
I THINK ONE THING IN GOVERNMENT
IS THAT WE COULD ALWAYS DO
BETTER AND IF WE LISTEN TO THOSE
THE RECEIVER SERVICES.
AND FROM THOSE THAT PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES WE CAN DO BETTER
TO REACH MORE AND AND HELP THOSE
IN NEED -- THERE IS THE
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN ONE OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS OR THE ENTIRE OR
CREATING AN ENTIRELY NEW ENTITY.
AND THEN WHAT WE REALLY FOCUSED
IN ON IS WORKING TO STREAMLINE
AND IMPROVE OUR SERVICES AND
CONDUCTING A PHASED APPROACH TO
CONSOLIDATION WITH THE KEY
EMPHASIS OF THAT GREATER
COLLABORATION.
WHICH WE HEARD FROM AS WE
CONDUCTED THOSE OUR REACH
OFFENSE AND SURVEYS IS THAT THEY
WERE LOOKING FOR CONSISTENCY AND
TO BE LISTENED TO AND REALLY
TAKING THEIR INPUT AND ADVICE
AND THEN PROGRAMMING GOES INTO
OUR RESPECTIVE DEPARTMENTS --
HAVING GONE THROUGH THREE
DIFFERENT CONSOLIDATIONS I
WITHIN -- YES SINCE -- TWO
THOUSAND FOUR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW IS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO INCLUDE THOSE THAT
WE SERVE AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND DO IT VERY METHODICALLY SO
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SHOULDN'T.
SUPPORT AND ATTENTION TO THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT AS WE WORK
THROUGH BUT AS WE SAID DOING
NOTHING WAS NOT AN OPTION AND
THAT GREATER COLLABORATION.
AS A JUST A FEW OF THE RESULTS
OF THAT COLLABORATION -- INCLUDE
ART JOINT PRESENTATIONS AS WE
HAVE SIMILAR STAKEHOLDERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM BOTH
DEPARTMENTS WE ARE CONDUCTING
MORE WEBINARS AND TRAINING AND
MEETING VENUES TO INCLUDE THEM
SO THAT WE'RE ALL SPEAKING WITH
ONE VOICE FROM THE VICTIM'S
PERSPECTIVE.
IN FACT OTHERS A JOINT WEAPON
ARE SCHEDULED FOR APRIL
SEVENTEENTH AND TWENTY SECOND TO
GET INPUT AND FEEDBACK FROM THE
FIELD AND THOSE THAT WE SERVE.
TO BETTER INFORM OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY AND SOME OF OUR OUR
EXISTING AND OUR NEW PROGRAMS --
WE'VE ADDED THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD TO THE
MEMBERSHIP OF OF SOME OF OUR THE
STEERING COMMITTEES THAT I
MENTIONED -- FOR VOCA INVOLVED
SO THAT THEY CAN HELP -- BE AT
THE TABLE WITH OUR MULTI
DISCIPLINE PARTNERS.
WE ALSO ARE WORKING ON A JOINT
REGIONAL TRAININGS.
BEAT SO THAT ARE OUR PARTNERS
THE NON PROFITS LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
PUBLIC SAFETY ENTITIES CAN KNOW
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AS A REACHING OUT TO THOSE
VICTIMS.
AND WE'RE ALSO COLLABORATING ON
A ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES TO
MAKE SURE AS WE HAVE IN STATE
RESPONSE TO MASS CASUALTIES
INCIDENT AT THE STATE LEVEL.
THAT WE ARE COORDINATED AND
UNIFIED AND THAT APPROACH --
WE'RE ADDING LANGUAGE AND OUR
REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS THAT GO
OUT TO OUR OUR SUB RECIPIENT SO
THAT THEY KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MULTIPLE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO SEEK
THOSE THAT COME FROM VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD AND THOSE
THAT COME FROM -- YES AND THAT
THOSE MIGHT EXIST WITHIN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES OVER THE CITIES THAT
THAT OFFER ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS
SO IT'S REALLY LOOKING AT IT
FROM AN ALL INCLUSIVE APPROACH
TO HOW WE MEET THE SERVICES --
AND THE STUDY REALLY HELPED
INFORM THAT AND WE HAVE NOW -- A
JOINT COMMITMENT WITH THAT CAN
KIND OF A A SHARED GOAL OF
WORKING TOGETHER WITH OUR
PARTNERS HEARING FROM THEM TO
STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE OUR
PROCESSES.
AND WITH THEIR INPUT AND REALLY
WORKING TO BENEFIT THOSE THAT WE
COLLECTIVELY SIR SO NOW IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BOTH OF OUR DEPARTMENTS
ARE HAPPY TO ENGAGE.
AS WE GO OUT THROUGH THE YEAR
AND CONTINUE THIS TO ENGAGE IN
OTHER CONVERSATIONS ON THE MORE
DETAILS OF THE REPORT.
A CONSOLIDATION DISCUSSIONS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR PROGRAMS.
AND SO WITH THAT I WILL
[inaudible]
CLOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES.
THAT ARE MORE LIKE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- MAYBE AGAIN JUST
GETTING REAL FUNDAMENTAL BUT WE
SHOULD MISS HAVE BEEN DONE
[inaudible]
YEARS AGO.
WELL AS YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN UNDERTAKEN -- TO TO
CONSOLIDATE AND IN FACT -- IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR WAS OF WHEN
THE OFFICE OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
FUNDING WAS CONSOLIDATED INTO
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
I DO TOO ARE THE CAPABILITY OF
OF GRANT MANAGEMENT AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND MULTI
AGENCY COORDINATION -- SO I
THINK THERE'S BEEN INTERESTS OF
PROGRESS MADE IN IMPROVING THE
PROGRAM BUT I THINK USING THAT
INFORMATION TO INFORM.
I'M WITH THIS NEW ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO DO I THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS AND THE CHALLENGES -- IS
THAT IT REALLY TAKES A LOT.
A AND AND BEING MINDFUL OF THE
IMPACTS TO THOSE THAT WE SERVE
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
OF THOSE THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO TO
VICTIMS -- AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE SENSITIVE TO ALL THE
DETAILS AGO INTO CONSOLIDATION.
I AM I WOULD AGREE AND I THINK
THAT'S I'M GONNA UNDERPINS THE
ARE THE RECOMMENDATION THAT WE
NOT MOVE QUICKLY TO TO
CONSOLIDATION -- RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS REPORT WAS DUE TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IN OCTOBER AFTER IT JULY
FIFTEENTH -- BUDGET IS A VER
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO REALLY
ADEQUATELY EXAMINED HOW
CONSOLIDATION MIGHT ACTUALLY
OCCUR SO MANY DETAILS BECAUSE
BOTH OF US.
RECEIVE SO MUCH FEDERAL FUNDING
THROUGH DIFFERENT -- ENTITIES
WITHIN.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- UP AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I'M SO
IS A LOT OF DETAILS THAT NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT AND WE WERE
SENSITIVE TO THAT -- AND THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT THAT ANY DELAYS
IN FUNDING BECAUSE OF
TRANSITIONING OR GRANT AWARDS
FROM ONE DEPARTMENT TO ANOTHER
MY BECAUSE OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
THAT'S WHY I IN THE AYE AYE
DETAIL THE RECOMMENDATION OF
SAYS THIS REALLY OUGHT TO BE
STUDIED MORE AND ARGO THROUGH
EITHER GOVERNOR'S REORGANIZATION
PLAN OR A LEGISLATIVE -- CHANGE
AND THAT THAT IS PROBABLY GOING
TO TAKE SOME TIME.
NOT PUTTING THEIR SPECIFIC TIME
FRAME ON IT BUT AS AS GRACE AS
INDICATED IN THE SHORTER TERM.
NOT WAITING FOR THAT TO HAPPEN
WE HAVE REALLY RAMPED UP OUR
EFFORTS. TO TO COORDINATE OUR
ACTIVITIES IN A MORE VISIBLE
MORE TRANSPARENT WAY SO THAT
VICTIMS AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS.
REALLY KNOW THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS UNITED ON THIS AND
THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ARE COMMITTED TO
DELIVERING THE BEST SERVICS
POSSIBLE.
SO WHETHER IT LOOKS A LITTLE
MESSY BECAUSE IT'S IN TWO
DIFFERENT PLACES WE'RE TRYING --
TO PRESENT AND PROVIDE THESE
PROGRAMS IN KIND OF A A SEAMLESS
MANNER SO THAT WHATEVER OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL CHALLENGES DON'T
BECOME A CHALLENGE OF THE
VICTIMS.
SO WHEN YOU MERGING DEPARTMENT
WITH ANOTHER DEPARTMENT YOU HAVE.
HOPEFULLY THE ELIMINATION OF
DUPLICATE POSITIONS.
THE HOUSE AT BEING ADDRESSED
WELL THOSE ARE THE VERY KEY
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THERE'S ISSUES OF ACCOUNTING
SYSTEMS AND TECHNOLOGIES SYSTEMS
AND H. R. OFFICES AND ALL THE
THINGS THAT ARE IN -- TO
DEPARTMENTS -- SO THOSE WILL ALL
BE ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT AND THEY NEED TO BE LOOKED AT
CAREFULLY AND REALLY PLANNED OUT.
AND NOT JUST ASSUME THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TO DO IT
WITHOUT ANY PROBLEMS WE REALLY
WANT TO PLAN IT OUT PLAN IT OUT
WELL.
ARE YOU BOTH USING THIS CAL YES
WE ARE AS I WORKING FOR YOU
[inaudible]
IT'S WORKING.
YES WE WERE WE WERE ACTUALLY ONE
OF THE OF THE FIRST FIRMS WERE
IN WAVE.
ONE AND THE WE'RE DOING FINE
THAT'S FOR THEIR SAKE YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SO THE IT WAS THE BUDGET ACTION
OF LAST YEAR.
THAT DIRECTED THIS -- WERE --
DELIBERATE EFFORT TOWARDS
CONSOLIDATION.
AND WHILE IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE
CASE THAT.
YOU KNOW THESE THINGS CAN'T JUST
BE DONE OVERNIGHT.
THE WHY I RE ITERATED THE
EXPECTATION OF THE REPORT BY
DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN IS
CERTAINLY.
A THAT'S MORE THAN A YEAR AND A
HALF.
YOU KNOW THAT WE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE -- TO THE IF WE WERE TRYING
TO CONSOLIDATE. TWO DEPARTMENTS
THAT WERE.
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE YOUR SIZED.
I'D HAVE MORE OF A YOU KNOW
MAYBE THAT COULD TAKE A FEW
YEARS AND YOU ALL DO SOME --
VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY.
DETAILED WORK IN CLEARLY GET
GRANTS FROM FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT YOU'RE IN THE SCHEME OF
THINGS IN TERMS AGES ARE NOT
THAT LARGE SO.
LET'S GET THE REPORT IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY NINETY IS LA -- HAVE
ANY COMMENT. ONE PERSON AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS -- WE DO YOU THINK THIS
REPORT IS A GOOD FIRST STEP --
CLEARLY THE THE AGENCIES WENT TO
QUITE A BIT OF EFFORT TO DO
OUTREACH TO LOOK AT WHAT OTHERS --
IT DOES SEEM THAT YOU KNOW IT
THAT.
ARE BEING THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW
THIS WOUL HAPPEN IS IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITIES --
HOWEVER WE DO THINK THAT THE
MAIN LIMITATION HERE OF COURSE
IS THAT THERE'S A LACK OF
CLARITY ON EXACTLY WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN WITH THIS CONSOLIDATION
WHERE WOULD GO -- WHEN IT WOULD
HAPPEN THOSE KINDS OF DETAILS SO
WE REALLY ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT DECEMBER REPORT WE THINK
THAT'S CRITICAL ON TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED -- FOR BOTH IN
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
FIRST AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY IN
BUDGET BILLING WHICH SHOWED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE IT
CLEAR A COUPLE OF TIMES THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING.
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR THEM TO
TO HAVE A REPORT ON SO WE THINK
WE THINK THAT DECEMBER REPORT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- AND WHEN THE
THE LEGISLATURE DOES REVIEW THAT
REPORT WE CONTINUE TO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE ONE ENTITY
REALLY FOCUSED ON VICTIMS
PROGRAMS AND SO -- SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THAT --
AND AND HOW THAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WITHIN THAT REPORT -- ALSO JUST
IN TERMS OF THAT THE SHORT TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS CERTAINLY SEEMS
REASONABLE TO DO SOME SOME INNER
ON THINGS AND AND GENERALLY SEEM
REASONABLE JUST ONE WHAT KIND OF
ISSUE THAT TO THINK ABOUT IS --
AND POTENTIALLY AS THE
DEPARTMENTS AS IF THERE ANY
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH ANY OF
THOSE INTERIM SUCH SOLUTIONS
BECAUSE REALLY WE VIEW THOSE AS
INTERIM SOLUTIONS AND SO -- IF
THEY ARE IF THERE ARE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE -- THAT
SHOULD BE PROBABLY WAIT IN THAT
CONTEXT.
I'M CHAIR IF I MAY I JUST HAVE
TO REITERATE THAT THE THE
DECEMBER REPORT IS A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE WORKING
GROUP BUT I DON'T THINK THERE'S
NECESSARILY COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT A REPORT WILL
BE PROVIDED I THINK WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND WORKING WITH THEM -- BUT
AGAIN I DON'T THINK THERE IS
LIKE COMMITMENTS THOUGHT THAT WE
WILL BE DOING OVER POOR IN
DECEMBER BUT IT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR US AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH BOTH
DEPARTMENTS.
DILIGENTLY ON THIS SO -- WE WILL
PROVIDE INFORMATION AS MUCH AS
WE CAN BUT AGAIN THERE'S NO
COMMITMENT TO A DECEMBER REPORT
FROM THE MINISTRATION.
RIGHT SO WHILE IT IS NOT IN THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT GAVE
THE DIRECTION TO DO THE
CONSOLIDATION DID NOT SPECIFY
DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN WITH
THE REPORTED DID OCTOBER
EIGHTEEN WHICH WE HAVE -- A
GIVEN THAT OUR INTEREST IS IN
DOING THE CONSOLIDATION.
BY MY REITERATING THE DESIRE FOR
THAT IT GIVES US THE ABILITY
[inaudible]
IN THE RURAL THAT BE THE END OF
THE NINETEEN NO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE YEAR. TO BE ABLE TO
ADOPT A BUDGET THAT REFLECTS.
A CONSOLIDATION.
AND WITHOUT SO IT WILL MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO SO.
SO.
IF ARM WE'LL GO BACK AND LOOK AT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER BILL
FROM BEFORE.
AND IF WE WERE NOT CLEAR ABOUT
SOME DATES MAY WILL PUT SOME IN
THIS YEAR.
AN GO AHEAD SENATOR MORE LACK.
GREAT BECAUSE THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A SUGGESTION
AND IN ORDER.
AND I'M I'M HERE IN ORDER. TO SO
I'M JUST WONDERING JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH WITH
NOVEMBER WORK OUT BETTER FOR YOU
TO GET IT DONE. FOR OCTOBER WAS
IT WOULD YOU PREFER THAT I THINK
WE STILL NEED TO WORK WITHIN THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUT AS ALWAYS --
THE BEST REPORTING TIME FOR
FINANCES ALWAYS JANUARY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET COMES OUT AND THAT'S
USUALLY WHEN OUR PLANS COME OUT
BUT AGAIN A WE ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH THE DEPARTMENTS
WE HAVE A VERY STRONG INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE -- SO
YEAH I MEAN WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM AS CLOSE AS WE CAN ON THIS
AND WHAT THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU MANAGER AS THEY SAY
DON'T QUIBBLE CIVIL AND
CERTAINLY JANUARY'S NOT SO BAD
COMPARED TO DECEMBER SO WHATEVER
WILL HAVE THE CONVERSATION MORE
WE'LL SEE WHETHER WE NEED TO PUT
ANYTHING SPECIFIC AND BUDGET
LANGUAGE OR NOT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BEFORE YOU GO
IS A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY SEEING NINE NOW I WANT TO
RETURN TO POSTS THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN PUBLIC COMING UP SOON I
AIRED AND DID NOT ASK FOR IT SO
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
POST.
IS IF THERE IS PLEASE COME TO
THE MIKE YOU CERTAINLY.
I APOLOGIZE FOR MY NOT HAVING
CALLED FOR IT.
THE NEXT.
FIVE ALL RIGHT THEN IF THERE'S
NOT ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
WE WILL GET TO MOVE ON AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE.
TO THE OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY UDER
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
FOR FIRE APPARATUS IN
MAINTENANCE SHOT.
I THINK WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
FOLKS [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
OUR I HAVE A THE STOUT AND THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
AND THE GOOD AFTERNOON IT SAID
MITCH MEDICAID HMO DIRTY
DIRECTOR FOR LOGISTICS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MERGING
SERVICES.
GREAT RED PROCEED THE PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU RIGHT NOW IS FOR
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND FOR A ONE TIME
PURCHASE.
OF THE FIRE APPARATUS
MAINTENANCE SHOP.
THIS IS LOCATED ABOUT A MILE AND
A HALF FROM OUR HELLO YES
HEADQUARTERS.
THE CURRENT WE ARE CURRENTLY
LEASING THE FACILITY AND THE
LEASE PROVIDES CALORIE S. WITH
THE OTION TO PURCHASE THE
FACILITY FOR TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IF PURCHASED BY JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
AFTER THAT DATE THE PURCHASE
PRICE WOULD GO UP.
I HAVE MISTER MITIGATE A CHAIR
WITH ME TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
SO WHAT THIS THE SHOP A CALLOW
YES MAINTAINS A FLEET OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AT ENGINES
CURRENTLY AND WE ALSO WATER
TENDERS.
OF THAT ARE DISTRIBUTED OUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY SAN WE DO
THAT AS PART OF OUR OUR MUTUAL
AID -- PACKAGE THAT WE HAVE OUT
THERE THE SHOP -- IS WHERE WE DO
THAT MAINTENANCE ON THOSE -- ON
THOSE ENGINES SO ONE THIRD
STREET IT LOCALLY -- LOCAL
MAINTENANCE IS PERFORMED THERE
BUT IT -- A LOT OF OUR
MAINTENANCE THIS IS BROUGHT FOR
TO OUR SITE HERE.
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT SHOP TAKES
PLACE IN THAT WORK IS DONE MA'AM
BUT ANOTHER HUNDRED ENGINES THAT
ARE.
HAVE BEEN -- ALSO INBOUND
THEY'RE COMING IN DIFFERENT
TYPES ENGINES AND I HAVE OUR OUR
CHIEF OF FIRE HERE -- CHIEF
MARSHALL WITH ME IS WELFARE ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON ON THAT
PORTION OF IT ADDITIONALLY WE TO
STOCKPILING OF SOME COMMODITIES
AND SO.
ARE THESE THE SAME COMMODITIES
THAT I'VE USED IN PUSHED OUT TO
ALL OF OUR RECENT FIRES AT YOU
SEEN SO WE HAVE -- COTS BLANKETS --
WATER -- KIDS OF THAT TYPE
ATTENDED CHURCH THAT I USE --
THEN WE'VE USED AND WE RESPOND
ACCORDINGLY LIKE WE DID IN SANTA
ROSA LIKE WE DIDN'T READING LIKE
WE DID IN -- RECENTLY IN
PARADISE AND OTHER AREAS AND SO
I HAD THIS IS WHERE WE MAINTAIN
THAT CASH.
ALONG WITH THOSE VEHICLES AND
WE'RE CONSTANTLY USING THIS OF
THEIR WE SEE THIS IS A GOOD
OVERALL INVESTMENT LONG TERM
IT'S BETTER FOR THE STATE IN
TERMS OF SAVING MONEY.
AND ALSO AVOID ANY DISRUPTION
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE BY TRYING
TO MOVE TO DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
IN THE LONG TERM AND CONSTANTLY
RE.
NO RELOCATING IS ROBBIE SEE AT
THE WOMEN SUBJECT OF OF THE
LANDLORD WHEN ONE OF THE
SITUATION.
LEASES STRUCTURE TO BUY AND WE
THINK IT'S A GOOD PROPOSALS WHEN
WE LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GREAT I'M I KNOW THAT. FIVE AS
YOU STATED THIS IS THE BUDGET
REQUEST IS TO PURCHASE THIS
FACILITY VERSUS LEASING IT.
AND I KNOW THAT THE LA -- RAISE
THE QUESTION OF IF -- WE ARE
PROCEEDING WITH THIS IN
PURCHASING THEN WOULDN'T THERE
BE A CONCOMITANT REDUCTION DUE
TO THAT WE'RE NO LONGER LEASING.
AND SO -- IT IS IS HAD YOU
ALREADY FACTOR THAT IS THAT
ALREADY INCORPORATED IN THIS
BUDGET REQUEST OR NOT.
SINCE THIS IS -- I THINK -- MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES MYSELF OF REYES
NUMBER OF TIMES.
WE WHENEVER WE HAVE DISCRETION --
GENERAL DISCRETIONARY GENERAL
FUND USES WE ARE TRYING TO BE
VERY -- CAREFUL AND SMART ABOUT
HIM BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
COMPETITION FOR GENERAL FUND SO.
YES MA'AM CHAIR IT'S NOT
CURRENTLY INCORPORATED IN THAT
PROPOSAL PORSCHE PARTIALLY
BECAUSE THE PART WE ANTICIPATE
PURCHASING THE FACILITY BY
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO UP UNTIL THAT TIME
WE WOULD STILL BE PAYING THE
LEASE.
ADDITIONALLY AFTER WE TAKE OVER
OWNERSHIP OF OF THE PROPERTY
THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL COSTS
FOR MAINTENANCE AND UTILITIES
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO FACTOR IN
THAT WOULD OFFSET ANY REDUCTION
[inaudible]
I'M.
SO THEN THE ONLY PART THAT I
THINK THAN WOULD BE CONFUSING IS
WE'RE REALLY BEING ASKED TO
WOULDN'T BE EXPENDED UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SALLY WE CAN
BUILD A PART IN A FINANCED SO --
WE WOULD.
EXERCISE THE THE PURCHASE OPTION --
SOMETIME BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THERE'S A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT HAVE TO BE.
RESOLVED BEFORE THAT ACQUISITION
ACTUALLY AKE PLACE.
AND THAT IS -- WE WOULD -- TASK
THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
WITH WITH DOING THEIR THEIR
BASIC REAL ESTATE DUE DILIGENCE
THAT THEY WOULD NORMALLY DO THAT
WE HAVE TO GET APPRAISALS --
THERE HAS TO BE A SEQUEL -- ACT
SIX ACTIVITIES UP.
PHASE ONE ENVIRONMENTAL REPORTS
POSSIBLY FEES TO DEPENDING ON
WHAT'S DISCOVERED IN PHASE ONE
SO THERE ARE NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE TO OCCUR.
BUT WE WOULD -- ENCUMBER THE
MONEY THAT THE FUNDS AND AND
HOLD THEM IN OUR FROM TOLD THE
TIME THAT THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE
DONE AND THEN WE CAN EXERCISE
THE OPTION [inaudible]
I'M.
I THINK WE'D WANT TO JUST.
MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER.
WE APPROPRIATED FOR THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY DID.
WAS SUGGESTED BY WHATEVER --
REDUCTION IN COSTS DUE TO NO
LONGER HAVING AT LEAST JUST SO
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY.
AN APPROVING THE THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY AMOUNT -- MENTOR IF I
COULD ADD TO THAT PLEASE -- SO
THE AMOUNT THAT'S BEEN QUESTED
HERE'S TWO POINT TWO MILLION AND
THAT'S THE EXACT AMOUNT THAT'S
NEEDED.
FOR THE TO EXERCISE THE OPTION
AND TO HAVE THESE YES ENGAGE IN
THE VARIOUS ACTIVITIES THAT THAT
ARE REQUIRED -- ANY REDUCTION TO
THAT AMOUNT WOULD.
THERE WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH.
IN FUNDING.
TO PROCEED WITH THE ACQUISITION
SO OF THE NORMAL PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD ENVISION IS THAT AFTER THE
ACQUISITION TAKES.
PLACE THEN BE BASED BUDGET OF
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE REDUCED
ACCORDINGLY BY THE THE SAVINGS
IN THE RENT.
I THINK I CAPTURED THE RIGHT ANY
OTHER.
YES SENATOR BELT -- YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU BY BUILDING IT LOOK AT
IT YOU MIGHT HAVE TO RE HAVE
BETTER FIX IT UP.
IS THAT INCLUDING THE CLUSTER.
I'M MORE FORTUNATE THAT.
THE ANSWER IS YES AND THEN AND
THE WERE FORTUNATE THAT WE'VE --
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE BUILDING
NOW SO WHEN WE THE WENT TO LEASE
THIS BUILDING WE DID HAVE TO DO
SOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT.
WERE INITIALLY STRUCTURES PART
AN AMORTIZATION THE EXPECTED
COME TO US AND ASK FOR MONEY TO
REHABILITATE THE BUILDING OR HOW
OLD IS THIS BILL.
I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT -- DATA
THE BILLING BUT I KNOW IT CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE DID SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BUILDING
BEFORE WE HAD OCCUPIED RECENTLY
SO.
TO IT'S NINETEEN NINETY SIX NINE
SIX THANKS SALLY.
ALERT ME.
SO SO THE QUESTION WOULD BE ARE
YOU KNOW LIKE NEXT YEAR WHEN YOU
COME AROUND TO THE BUDGET TIME
ARE YOU GOING TO SAY WELL WE
NEED A COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS.
EXCEPT UPPER WHAT MOUNTAINS
STORY THERE THERE'S NO
ANTICIPATION OF HAVING TO COME
TO A FOR THAT CAN I CAN I CAN'T
SAY THAT THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT I CAN TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THE AND A LOT OF THAT
WILL BE VOTED OUT THROUGH THE
DUE DILIGENCE.
PROCESS A LOOKING AT THE
BUILDING AND TO VALIDATE THE OF
THE ASSOCIATED -- PRICES SO CITY
WITH.
IT'S KIND OF NICE AND THOUGH.
WITH THE LOOMING IF WE HAVE THE
PURCHASE OF A YES SIR THAT'S
PART OF WHAT APARTMENT I'M
EXCUSE ME DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES WILL LOOK AT THE OLD DO
I INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY AND
THEY'LL ASSESS THE BILL THE
CONDITION OF THE BUILDING BUT
WE'RE TOLD THAT THE BUILDING IS
IN VERY.
GOOD CONDITION.
SO WE DON'T ANTICIPATE ANYTHING
FURTHER.
I LET ME SEE IF THEIR CENTER
MORE LOOK AHEAD -- NO REAL
ESTATE ACQUISITION IS A FUN.
YES AGAIN ASKING BASIC QUESTIONS.
DOES THE G. S. HAVE A THE
MAJORITY OF THE ALREADY OWNED
PROPERTIES THAT YOU COULD.
UTILIZE OR EMAIL BACKGROUND ON
HOW YOU FOUND THIS PROPERTY IN.
OUT OFFICE IN.
SHIRT SO -- WE HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED A LIST OF ANYTHING THAT
WOULD BE SUITABLE FOR US TO USE
AND WHEN WE WENT THROUGH OUR
WHEN WE WENT TO GET THIS LEASE
FOR THIS PROPERTY THAT WE HAD.
WE WORK THROUGH DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES ORIGINALLY TO
GET THE SPACE WERE CURRENTLY
OCCUPYING RIGHT NOW SO.
THEY ASSIST US THEY DO A OF THE
SEARCH FORCE THEY ALSO --
CONDUCT -- THAT PART OF THEIR
DILIGENCE TO LOOK AT WHAT OTHER
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO US --
THEY ASSISTED US WE LOOKED AT
MULTIPLE SITES.
AND WE WHITTLE IT DOWN TO THIS
PARTICULAR SITE -- AND THEN WENT
IN AND HAD TO DO SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SITE AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS -- READY
FOR US TO PUT THESE.
ON HIGH DOLLAR ENGINES -- THAT
ARE THERE ARE SOME EXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT SO WE WENT THROUGH --
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE SECURE
SECURITY MEASURES WERE PUT IN
THE ROOF AND AND OTHER -- ITEMS
WERE -- IS SATISFACTORY FOR US --
TO OCCUPY INTAKE -- A USE OF THE
SPACE WAS THERE SO THAT'S THAT
WAS PART OF ALL OF HAT DUE
DILIGENCE.
EARLY ON TO FIND AN ACCEPTABLE
PLACE FOR US TO ESTABLISH THE
SHOP AND WAREHOUSE THAT WE
CURRENTLY USE THERE AND SO.
FORTH.
YOU HAVE AN OPTION TO PURCHASE.
AND SO RIGHT NOW REAL ESTATE IS
DOING PRETTY WELL.
AND WE'RE FORTUNATELY --
ESTABLISH THE THE LEASES TIME WE
PUT IN A LEASED BY OR PURCHASE
OPTION INTO THIS -- IT'S FIXED
FORCE RIGHT NOW IT TWO MILLION ---IF WE GO BEYOND THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MARK THEN IT ASSERTS
A 3% ESCALATION.
OF FOR THAT COSTS -- OUR TIME
NOW.
IF WE MAKE THIS DECISION NOW
OBVIOUSLY WILL SAVE MORE MONEY
AND THE LESS MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING INTO RENT AS WE GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS THE ANYTIME
WE EXERCISE IT.
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT BECOMES
BETTER FORCE EARLIER -- THERE'S
ALSO SIGNS IN THE MARKET PLACE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE MAY BE HEADING
TOWARDS A RECESSION.
WHICH COULD MEAN THAT.
MIGHT BE TOO I HAVE A PURCHASE
PRICE WHAT KIND OF STOP GAP DO
YOU HAVE -- HOW DO YOU PUT THE
BRAKES ON TO SAY YOU KNOW MAYBE
THIS ISN'T THE RIGHT THING JUST
TGS?
GET ANOTHER APPRAISAL EVERY SIX
MONTHS OR A YEAR.
OURS IS THE IS THE PRICE MAY BE
CONSIDERED THE MINIMUS TWO TWO
MILLION IS.
I WANTED I DON'T MINIMIZE ANY
AMOUNT BUT IT IS SORT OF THE
BUDGET DOES KIND OF IT.
YOU KNOW AGREED AND AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS
GOES BACK TO THE THE SAME DUE
DILIGENCE THAT -- COMES LOOKING
BILL ALREADY SPOKE TO AND
THEY'RE GONNA COME BACK AND DO
THAT THAT PROCESS.
UNDER THE FORMAL PROCESS TO DO
THAT -- AS PART OF THAT SEARCHES
FOR THAT EVALUATION AND IT GOES
THROUGH THE A PUBLIC WORKS SPORT
AS PART OF OUR OUR NORMAL
ACQUISITION PROCESS AND THAT
WILL.
OF THAT OUT ANY ISSUES THAT WE
SEE -- DISCREPANCIES AND MAY
FORCE US TO GO BACK AND SAY WE
NEED TO RE NEGOTIATE THE PRICE
AT THAT POINT TIME BUT ALL RIGHT
NOW WERE WERE FORTUNATE WITH THE
MARKET HOT THAT WE'VE BUILT IN
THAT -- OF FIXED PRICE POINT
RIGHT NOW FOR FOR PURCHASE TO
BUY.
SO AS A AS A LEGISLATOR IT'S A
LITTLE DIFFERENT TO BEING LIKE --
SIR BALLOT OR SUPERVISORS SO WE
WE HAD DEPARTMENT HAS SINCE I'M.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THIS YOU
KNOW EVEN AFTER BEING HERE FOR A
FEW YEARS HEALTH DEPARTMENTS RUN
AND WHETHER MANAGE PROPERLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
I DON'T GET TOO MANY CHANCES TO
THAT SIDE I KNOW I MET WITH --
MISTER I I LOVE HIS LAST NAME.
GILARDI G..
RECORD GUILTY YES SIR YEAH SO --
HE STRIKES ME AS A SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERT BUT SOME OF THE
BILLS I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
ISSUES I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW
ARTICLES I'VE READ LIKE.
I KIND OF WONDER HOW DO YOU
MANAGE YOU KNOW. TO ANALYZE OR
CRITIQUE OR HELP OR YOU KNOW A
DEPARTMENT SO HOW IS -- ES DOING
AS A DEPARTMENT.
IF I COULD ASK YOU IT.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE I DON'T
HAVE MARK HERE.
I'M PROBABLY A LITTLE BIASED I
WOULD SAY TO YOU THAT I THINK
WE'RE DOING VERY WELL -- I THINK --
THE EVENTS THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- THE NUMBER OF
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATIONS THE
SCOPE AND MAGNITUDE OF THE
DISASTER THAT WE FACED.
AND THE RESPONSE THAT -- CALLOW
S. IS ENGAGED IN AND AND HOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING HAND IN HAND
WITH OUR FEDERAL AND COUNTY AND
CITY PARTNERS -- SPEAKS WELL TO
WHAT WE'VE DONE -- BUT ONCE
AGAIN IT HI I'M PROBABLY BIASED
BECAUSE I'M INTERNAL THAT AYE
AYE THE FEEDBACK THAT I RECEIVE
AND THAT I THINK ALL MY FELLOW
EXECUTIVES RECEIVE FROM --
EVERYONE THAT WE WORK WITH HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN POSITIVE IN THIS
LAST -- THREE YEARS.
THE LAST YEAR IN BUDGET WE HAD A
REQUEST FROM O. E. S..
ANY GET BEAT UP I MEAN WAS
CRITICIZED THAT IT WAS NOT A
PRETTY LITTLE EXERCISE SO WHAT.
WILL THE CAN WE DO TO HELP YOU.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE -- WE
CAN -- YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
ACQUISITION FIRE SHOP WHERE ELSE
TO ENSURE THAT THESE ENGINES ARE
MAINTAINED IN USED. FOR
FIREFIGHTING OPERATIONS AT THE
COMMODITIES -- PROPERLY -- STAGE --
BEYOND THAT -- THERE'S A SERIES
OF PROPOSALS THAT CALLAWAY'S HAS
AND WE WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT CENTER.
THANKS FOR LET ME HAS SOME
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIR
I JUST. THIRTY NINE WITH IT
BEING A LEGISLATORS ALL AT
DIFFERENT TO BE AN EXECUTIVE.
SUPERVISORS AUTUMN.
I'M TRYING TO GROW INTO THE ROLE
THANKS.
YOU'RE WELCOME AND WE ARE AS
MEMBERS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE WE
ARE CHARGED WITH THAT THE REASON
WE HAVE HEARINGS IS FOR
OVERSIGHT OF THE BUDGET SO.
CERTAINLY -- PRECIADO OFFICE.
COMING.
BETTER AT IT SO DO MANY
QUESTIONS RIGHT BEFORE I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
OKAY SO THE MOTION I WOULD
ENTERTAIN IS THAT WE WOULD A
PROOF AS BUDGETED -- WITH THE
REDUCTION COMMENSURATE TO
REFLECT.
THAT THE FACILITY WOULD BE OWNED --
THAT AT THE POINT THAT THE SALE
WAS CONCLUDED.
SO WITH THAT IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION LET'S DO
ROLL CALL CENTER SKINNER HI AND
MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANKS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
A CENTER RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
ISSUE SIX THE INTER.
OPERABLE PUBLIC SAFETY RADIO
SYSTEM.
SAME FOLKS GO AHEAD.
THOUGH THIS REQUEST IS FOR
APPROXIMATELY TEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
IN EIGHT POSITIONS AND NINETEEN
TWENTY TO START A FIVE YEAR
PROJECT.
THE TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT
WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND.
AND IT WOULD ALLOW THIS STATE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL PUBLIC SAFETY
RESPONDER IS TO SEAMLESSLY
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER
ACROSS MOST OF THE STATE.
I KNOW SOMETIMES WE GET INTO A
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL -- AREAS
THAT SAW -- I DON'T WANT TO GET
ANYTHING THAT WILL GO -- OUTSIDE
OF OUR AREA THAT.
IT TOO COMPLEX BUT WE SEE THIS
IS A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
TO CONNECT THESE THIRTY EIGHT
DESPAIR -- STATE NETWORKS THAT
ARE LOCATED LIKE LILLY PADS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE -- AND IF WE
BRING THIS PROPOSAL TOGETHER
WILL BE ABLE TO CONNECT THESE
NETWORKS TOGETHER AND THEREFORE.
ALLOW A FIRST RESPONDER TO
SEAMLESSLY MOVE FOR PRIMARY
LOCATION LOCATION.
AND A CONTINUE COMMUNICATE
EXACTLY WHERE THEY ARE.
AND THEN.
LONG TERM -- ONCE THIS IS BEEN
BUILT OUT -- THERE'S SAID A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
INTERFACE WITH LOCALS BECAUSE
THERE'S LOTS OF LOCAL NETWORKS
AS WELL -- ORANGE COUNTY HAS ONE
FOR EXAMPLE IN.
THAT IS THE SAN DIEGO ONE AND
MANY OTHERS THAT ARE OUT THERE
SO THAT WILL LA.
AND WILL LOOK TO CONNECT TO
THOSE AND SO -- ULTIMATELY --
WHEN YOU MOVE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE YOU'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE
SEAMLESSLY ON A NETWORK SIMILAR
TO WHAT YOU DO ON EIGHTEEN T.
RIGHT NOW WITH THE?
SUBSCRIBER AND OR OR VERIZON OR
ANY OTHER NETWORK THAT YOU MOVE
ON YOU JUST TRANSITIONING
BETWEEN SITE TO SITE AS OPPOSED --
TO LITTLE ISLANDS AND MOST OF US
ARE HERE REMEMBER THE EARLY DAYS
OF CELL AND THAT'S EXACTLY WE
USED TO DO WHEN WE WOULD BOUNCE
AROUND.
AND A DROP OFF AND COME BACK WE
HAD CONNECTIVITY.
QUESTION I HAVE IS WHAT DO WE
EXPECT THAT THROUGH THIS OF FIVE
THIS IS A FIVE YEAR ALLOCATION
THAT WE WILL ACHIEVE.
INTEROPERABLE SERVICES SERVICE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND I ASK
BECAUSE I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL.
DURING THE OAKLAND BERKELEY
TUNNEL FIRE.
AND ONE OF THE WHILE IT MOVED
VERY FAST AND WOULD HAVE HAD
REALLY DAMAGING CONSEQUENCES
REGARDLESS.
WHEN WE INVOKED MUTUAL AID?
WE FOUND AND ALSO THE BERKELEY
OAKLAND TOTAL FIRE DID.
REALLY HIT THREE JURISDICTIONS
BOTH THE CITY'S A BERKELEY
CITIES OAKLAND AND SOME
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY AREA AND
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT?
OUR AGENCIES COULD NOT
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER.
AND SOLVE OUR EMERGENCY SERVICE
PERSONNEL WERE BEING SPIED THE
COULD NOT COMMUNICATE.
AND THE THERE WERE OTHER YEP
THERE WERE LOTS OF RACERS
PROBLEMS AND IT IN FACT WE DID
NOT GET.
FULLY INTEROPERABLE SERVICE.
THERE WAS.
EIGHTY NINE WE DO NOT FINALLY
CHEAP IT UNTIL.
MID TO REWRITE BEFORE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT SO THAT WAS A
LONG TIME COMING AND THERE
WEREN'T EVEN THAT MANY AGENCIES
BUT ANYWAY SO IF YOU COULD
ANSWER THAT [inaudible]
I'M.
I WOULD COMMENT THAT I THINK
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT -- THE
CHALLENGES FOR COMMUNICATIONS
COME UP -- AND ALMOST EVERY
MAJOR DISASTER AND LOCATION IT'S
THEIR THEY'RE STILL GONNA BE
CHALLENGES BEYOND THIS WE'VE
SECOND TREMENDOUS STEPS -- FOR
FAMILIARITY WITH THE THE
COMMITTEE I NOW WITH FIRE SCOPE --
THE FIRE COMMUNITY DOES A MUCH
BETTER JOB ACTUALLY PRESET
FREQUENCIES -- WHERE --
EVERYBODY LOAD SIMILAR AND
THERE'S THERE'S DESIGN
FREQUENCIES FOR INTER OPERABLE A
MUTUAL AID RESPONSE OF FOR THEM
SO. TWO ONE AGE.
ENGINES -- COME IN AND AS YOU
PROBABLY SAW -- WITH THE FIRES
WE HAD SANTA ROSA WERE WE HAD --
ALL OF THE FEDERAL ASSETS WITH
MUTUAL AID COMING IN FROM ALL
OVER THE WESTERN UNITED STATES
AND AND AS FAR AWAY AS OVERSEAS --
THE INTEROPERABLE CONSTANT WAS
NOT AN ISSUE.
OF FOR YOU THAT WAS NOT
SOMETHING THAT SURFACED IN THAT
PARTICULAR -- FIRE PIECE TO IT.
WHAT CHANGES IN THIS PROPOSAL
FOR YOU IS?
IF YOU WERE IF YOU'RE IN ONE
AREA FOR EXAMPLE -- FEWER CDC
ARE IN YOUR TO PRISON THERE'S A
NICE NETWORK RIGHT THERE THAT
PRISON.
SOON AS YOU LEAVE THAT PRISON
AREA AND STRUGGLING A PRISONER
TRANSPORT OR SOMETHING ELSE THAT
YOU'RE DOING -- YOU DROP OFF AND
THEN WHEN YOU GET YOUR NEXT
NETWORK YOU'RE BACK ON IF YOU
CONNECT THESE NETWORKS THROUGH
INTERFACES AND PATHWAYS AND USE
OUR BACKBONE THAT WE HAVE WITHIN
THE STATE.
YOU CAN NOW SEAMLESSLY TRAVEL UP
AND DOWN AND THEN THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE IN THE MONEY
THAT WE SPENT ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE.
EARLY ON TO BUILD THE LOCAL
NETWORK CITY SABIR X. LA RICK'S --
SAN DIEGO -- THIS THE VALLEY
THERE'S THERE'S A THE LILY PADS
THAT EXIST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THERE'S A LONG TERM
STRATEGICALLY YOU'RE ABLE TO
THEN START MIGRATING CONNECTING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
AND THEN YOU JUST START
SUBSCRIBING AND IT'S A VERY.
SEAMLESS INTERFACE AT THAT POINT
ONCE YOU'VE BUILT -- THAT THAT --
TECHNOLOGICAL CONNECTION.
YOU'RE YOU'RE CONFIDENT THAT.
REASONABLY CONFIDENT THAT WE BE --
JEEP THIS IN THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD WE ARE AND WERE FOR YES I
AM A CHAIRMAN AND AND WE HAVE
OTHER STATES THAT WE'VE USED TO
MODEL FROM AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE
RE FEEL COMFORTABLE SAYING THAT
TINA.
I KNOW THAT THE LA -- HAD A
ROUND RAISE THE POINT THAT THIS
THE ACTION IS BOTH.
THE ARM.
APPROVAL OF THE FUNDING FOR THIS
FIVE YEAR PROGRAM BUT THEN ALSO
AN ON GOING.
APPROVAL FOR THE WORK LOAD FOR
THE MAINTENANCE AND I THINK
THERE -- THE LA -- WANTED TO
RAISE THE POINT THAT PERHAPS WE
WON'T KNOW HE YET IN FIVE YEARS
WHAT THAT.
WORKLOAD MIGHT BE SO.
ESSENTIALLY -- THERE MIGHT BE
SOME EFFICIENCIES ASSOCIATEDWITH ONCE THIS -- SYSTEM IS
FINALLY INTEGRATED AND YOU DON'T
HAVE THIRTY DESPERATE SYSTEM
THAT YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN.
THIRTY EIGHT I'M EXCUSE ME BUT
ALSO JUST BECAUSE THAT LEVEL OF
WORKLOAD TO BUILD THE SIZE
SYSTEM MIGHT BE DIFFERENT.
FROM THE LEVEL REQUIRED TO
OPERATE IT SO THAT WAS A
RECOMMENDATION.
FIND IT ACROSS A LOT MORE BUT
THAT NOT MEANING THIS WORKLOAD
DEPENDING ON WHATEVER I'M ANYWAY
[inaudible]
BUT CENTER MORE LIKE AND THEN
I'M GONNA GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AN HONOR IN A MOTION GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MISTER SMITH BIGGER WHICH A
MEDIC OF EDGE BUT YES SIR I HAD
A BIGGER VISION OKAY THANK YOU
MITCH -- HOW DOES THIS RELATE?
TO THE FIRE DRILL WE DID LAST.
INTERCESSIONS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WITH THE PHONE.
TAXPAYERS IS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
PROJECT.
ABSOLUTELY A DIFFERENT THIS IS
SO SOLELY FOR A RADIO THIS IS
TAKING THE RADIO IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT YOUR FIRST RESPONDERS
CHP HELLFIRE.
FISHING GAME OF FISH WILDLIFE
ANYBODY.
SEE CORRECTIONS ANYBODY WHO HAS
A RADIO IT'S EITHER IN THE CAR
OR MOTORCYCLE AIRCRAFT FOR
VEHICLE WERE ON THEIR PERSON.
THIS IS CONNECTING TO A NOT A
MICROWAVE NETWORK THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GEORGE COUNTY
WHICH HAS THE EIGHT HUNDRED
MEGAHERTZ AND I'VE BEEN ALL WITH
THAT. FOR SOME TIME SO I CAN I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE MAKE SURE
THAT I WASN'T STEPPING INTO.
IN SODIUM OR YOU COUNTY IS A
VERY GOOD ONE AS YOU KNOW AS YOU
KNOW A VERY GOOD ONE IT'S NICE.
IT WORKS REALLY WELL FURTHER
FURTHER AREA -- AT IF YOU'RE
TRANSITIONING OUT THEN OF COURSE
YOU COME OFF THAT NETWORK.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU [inaudible]
FOR WORK [inaudible]
ON FINALLY [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
CENTER SKINNER ART CENTER
MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK CHAIRMAN THANK CENTERS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL PLAN
ON GOING TO PRE POSITIONING
ACTIVITIES.
THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF ONE
TIME LEGISLATIVE UP OF
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED.
AND EVERY YEARS.
AND OF ITS TO SUPPORT PRE
POSITION ACTIVITIES FOR ALL
HAZARD EVENT.
I HAD CHIEF MARSHAL HERE WHO CAN.
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE
PROGRAM WORKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE PRE
POSITIONING SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
IS AN INSURANCE POLICY NGUYEN
PREDICTED WHETHER -- EITHER FOR
FIRE OR WILDLAND FIRE OR A FLOOD
EVENT [inaudible]
IS PREDICTED [inaudible]
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS PUT TOGETHER
A WORKSHEET THAT IS SUBMITTED TO
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AND BASED ON SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
WE PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE UP
STAFFING IN A PARTICULAR AREA.
TO PROVIDE THAT INSURANCE WERE
WE HAVE FIRE APPARATUS WE HAVE
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS
HELICOPTERS WHATEVER RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED.
SO WE CAN ATTACK -- AN EMERGENCY
FAST AND MINIMIZE THE DAMAGE.
AND MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS TO OUR
PUBLIC.
AMADOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANT TO ADD A LITTLE BIT OF
CLARIFICATION BASED ON THE STAFF
CAUGHT RECOMMENDATION ABOUT THE
FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVED -- IN
THE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THEY RECEIVED AT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND -- IT HAS TAKEN A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME -- FOR YES TO
SPEND THAT DOWN I THINK THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE STRICTER
REQUIREMENTS WHEN USING G. G. R.
F..
IT WAS LIMITED I BELIEVED ONLY
FIRE HAZARDS NOT ALL HAZARDS --
SO IT HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGING BUT THEY ARE WORKING
THROUGH IT AND STARTING TO SPEND
IT DOWN -- IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
THIS YEAR THERE IS A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED A
GENERAL FUND AND FOR THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OR SO IT WAS -- USED
TO PURCHASE EQUIPMENT AND TOOLS --
BUT THEN SB NINE OH ONE WHICH
BECAME EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST
CHANGE THAT PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW THEM TO USE IT FOR PRE
POSITIONING FOR ALL HAZARDS.
SO YES REALLY ONLY HAS SIX
MONTHS REALLY TO SPEND THAT
MONEY ON PRE POSITIONING -- AND
WE THINK THAT THESE THESE
RESOURCES ARE CRUCIAL THEY DO
HELP WITH RESPONDING TO ALL
TYPES OF HAZARDS OF FOR PRE
POSITIONING OUR RESOURCES AND SO
WE DO THINK THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
AND CONTINUING UP INVESTMENT IN
THAT -- IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
WELL THE COMMENT I WOULD MAKE IS
THAT -- AGAIN JUST THIS IS IN
GENERAL FUND THIS IS THE BUT HAS
LOTS OF COMPETITION AND WHILE I
THINK THERE'S CLEARLY SOME CLEAR
NEEDS IN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZE THEM AN
INCREASE.
IT MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE TO IT
WHERE YOU MAY BE APPROPRIATE TO
MODIFY IT BECAUSE JUST THE IF
YOU KNOW DEPARTMENTS ABILITY. TO
TO SPEND THE FINES.
WITHIN TIME PERIOD SO I THINK
WHAT WE'D WANT TO DO AND ALL ON
THE LA -- NEXT BUT WHAT WE'D
WANT TO DO IS HOLD THIS OPEN
[inaudible]
AND SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
ASSESSMENT.
OF WHAT THE NEED IS CLOSER TO
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR AND A
B. C. P. ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
SINCE WE DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT
NOW [inaudible]
I'M -- A DID YOU WANT TO COMMENT.
THAT'S EXACTLY IN LINE WITH OUR
COMMENTS AND WE DID KNOW BOTH
FOR THIS ITEM IN THE NEXT ITEM
THAT -- WILL BE HEARD I BELIEVE
THAT THERE WEREN'T BC PIECES
THERE WASN'T THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT WOULD TYPICALLY
RECEIVE ON A PROPOSAL -- AND ONE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL IS IS A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE ON
GOING NEED CERTAINLY PRE
POSITIONING -- SEEMS LIKE HAS A
LOT OF VALUE IN CAN MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE I'M AS WAS MENTIONED BY
IDEA LAUGH -- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN -- A LITTLE
BIT SLOWER GETTING THIS OUT NO
COURSE THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM SO
SOME OF THAT'S TO BE EXPECTED --
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THEY SPEND
APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO FAR ONE
POINT FIVE SO IT'S JUST
UNCERTAIN WHETHER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IS RIGHT ABOUT MAYBE IT
SHOULD BE MORE MAYBE SHOULD BE
LESS -- SO IT SEEMS LIKE A
PRUDENT APPROACH -- TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME FOR FOR A
MORE THOROUGH ASSESSMENT.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY REALLY
QUICK I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE CLEAR THAT THE THE MONEY
THAT'S PROPOSE FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A GENERAL
FUND ONGOING COMMITMENT NOT.
YEAH IT IS ONGOING AND I THINK
JUST TOUCH ON THE BCP QUESTION I
THINK THE REASON WE DIDN'T
PREPARE ONE FOR THE SPECIFICALLY
AND THE NEXT ONE THAT -- MISS
CHRISTINE MENTION IS BECAUSE
THESE WERE ALLEGED COMMITMENTS
FROM LAST YEAR AND THAT WE'RE
JUST COMMITTING ON GOING FUNDING
FOR THESE PURPOSES.
AND SO -- I THINK THAT'S WHY WE
DIDN'T DO IT BUT YEAH THIS IS A
GENERAL FUND.
PROPOSAL FOR THE BUDGET.
THAT CLARIFICATION BY THINK WE
pA B. C. P. ON IT JUST BECAUSE
WHILE I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
UNDERMINE THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION.
IF WE KNOW THAT WE WOULD ONLY BE
ABLE TO SPEND.
BOBBY -- I'M FROM PEOPLE
COMPLETELY GRABBING OUT OF THE
YEAR NUMBER RIGHT NOW TEN
MILLION IN THAT NEXT FISCAL YEAR
THEN WE'D WANT TO ONLY
APPROPRIATE THAT AMOUNT.
SO ANY QUESTION OR COMMENT
CENTER MORE LACKEY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- CHIEF MARSHALLED
BUT YOU'VE GOT A BIG STATE AND
IT'S LIKE -- FOR ME IT'S LIKE UP
WITH A FOUR GAME OR WITH A WAR
GAME ACTUALLY WHERE YOU HAVE ALL
YOUR RESOURCES AROUND STATE.
AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS.
HOW?
HOUSE BEEN WORKING SO FAR -- IN
ANTICIPATING -- ZERO HUMIDITY.
UP YOU KNOW DAY IN AND AND HOW
DID IT WORK LET'S SAY FOR SOME
OF THE RECENT.
FIRES AND WHAT ARE WE LEARNING
AND WHAT CAN WE IMPROVE ON WELL
I CAN TELL YOU AGAIN IT'S A IT'S
AN INSURANCE POLICY IT'S WORKING
GOOD WE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT IS A BRAND
NEW PROGRAM -- WERE USING IT FOR
ALL HAZARDS NOT JUST THE
WILDLAND FIRE BUT THE FLOODS AND
WE SEE THE POTENTIAL FOR MASSIVE
FLOODING IN THE BURN SCARS A
LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO WHEN THE PROCESS IS PUT INTO
PLACE I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE
HAVE HAD SUCCESS STORIES.
BECAUSE A ITS SURGE CAPACITY IN
A COMMUNITY AND BASED ON THE
WEATHER WERE ABLE TO THROW
EVERYTHING BUT THE KITCHEN SINK.
TO AN EMERGENCY AND THE SUCCESS
RATE IS A LOT BETTER THAN HAVING
TO CALL FOR THOSE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND THEY RESPOND --
BUT FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WERE ABLE TO GET THESE RESOURCES
WERE PREDICTED WHETHER BASED ON
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
THOSE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED.
WE HAVE A RECENT SUCCESS STORY --
A RECENT SUCCESS STORY.
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY -- THEY HAD
PRE POSITION RESOURCES FOR A
FLOOD EVENT.
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO GO OUT AND
MAKE RESCUES.
AND EVEN MORE SO THEY WERE ABLE
TO HAVE.
PEOPLE THAT WERE MANAGING THE
INCIDENT THE RESOURCES STAGE AND
THEY WEREN'T IMPACTING THEIR DAY
TO DAY ROUTINE ACT.
ACTIVITIES THAT THEIR FIRE
DEPARTMENTS TASK WITH.
SO THEY WERE ABLE TO COMMIT
RESOURCES TO AN INCIDENT AND
CONTINUE THEIR DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS SO -- THE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENTS
CONTACTED US AND TOLD US THANK
YOU GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU CHIEF MARSHALL THANK
YOU MISTER BURTON WE DO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS SIDE
OF MADAM CHAIR AT THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- JEFF MASTON REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
WE WORK VERY -- WEBER
COLLABORATIVE OF THE WITH
EVERYONE TRYING TO PUT THIS
CONCEPT TOGETHER AND JUST WANT
TO BRING A FEW THINGS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ONE IS -- WHEN
YOU PRE POSITIONED RESOURCES
THEY BECOME A STATE ASSET?
AND THAT'S VERY VALUABLE TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN THERE
ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED OUR PURPOSE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
WHEN WE LOOK AT THESE PROECTIVE
SERVICES WE UNDERSTAND THAT
EVENTS WILL HAPPEN OR THEY'RE
LIKELY TO OCCUR WE CAN PUT THEM
WHERE THEY BELONG AND THERE
ISN'T THAT THE LATE BECAUSE
SECONDS COUNT?
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THE PRE
POSITIONING MONEY WILL BE TO ADD
SOME TECHNOLOGY TO THE SYSTEM --
NOW ALL OUR FIRE APPARATUS SOME
DO AND SOME DON'T.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE.
IT ISN'T LIKE UBER WHERE WE CAN
SEE AN APP AND FIGURE OUT WHERE
APPARATUSES SO -- SOMETIMES THE
CLOSEST APPARATUS TO THE
INCIDENT DON'T GET DISPATCHED OR
ART ASSIGNED TO THE INCIDENT
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE SO THAT'LL BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THING.
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S -- MUTUALLY SYSTEM
IS ONE OF THE FINEST IN THE
COUNTRY IT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY AND AFTER LAST
COUPLE SIGNIFICANT YEARS OF FIRE.
A WE COLLECTIVELY THROUGH FIRE
SCOPE AND OTHER BODIES THAT DOWN
SO WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
BETTER WE'RE NOT SERVICING THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
APPROPRIATELY ONE OF THE EASIEST
QUICKEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE
THINGS WE'VE DONE IS.
ESTABLISH PRE POSITIONING SO THE
THE BEAUTY OF IT IS AS YOU USE
IT WHEN YOU NEED IT WHEN YOU
DON'T NEED IT YOU DON'T USE IT
YOU DON'T PAY FOR IT.
SO WE'RE REALLY POSITIVE ABOUT
IT -- I REPRESENT NOT ONLY THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS BUT IN
THIS CASE FAR DISTRICTS IS
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
METROPOLITAN FIRE CHIEFS.
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES FIRE CHIEFS --
AND WE COLLECTIVELY WORK WITH A
WE HAS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED
WITH THE PROGRAM L. ONLY REFINE
ITSELF.
AND THE CITIZENS OUR STATE WILL
GET WHAT THEY REALLY DESERVE AND
THAT'S SUPERIOR FIRE PROTECTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
REALLY PRE J. YOUR BEING HERE
AND SHARING THAT -- REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
I'M WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS OPEN.
AND SIR SURE SURE SENATOR BREAUX
JUST THE FROM THE LOOK THE LOOK
INTO FOR ME.
OF WE HAD AN INCIDENT IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT
WHERE THEIR RADIO.
AND THEIR PHONE THEY WERE TRYING
TO CALL EACH OTHER ON THE PHONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT IS
BEING DONE IN THE MUTUAL AID
PROGRAMS.
TO NOT LET THAT HAPPEN AGAIN
WHERE THEY WORK THE PHONE
COMPANY CANCEL THEIR PHONE
AGREEMENT.
DURING THE FIRE WHILE THEY WERE
TRYING TO CALL CONTACT EACH
OTHER.
A FEW MEMBER THAT'S PRETTY IT
WAS PRETTY.
THEY WERE TRYING TO CALL.
ON THE PHONE FOR MORE QUICK
MEANT FROM SOMEBODY AND THEN.
THEY GOT THE PHONE COMPANY SAID
OKAY WE'RE NOT GONNA YOU RUN OUT
OF YOUR TIME YOU KNOW.
THE CUT YOU OFF.
SO I JUST I JUST WANT.
YOU'D LOOK INTO THAT AND REPORT
BACK TO ME ON THAT PLEASE.
I'LL BE A HAPPY TO DO THAT
CENTER THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THANKS I'M GOING TO
JUMP OUT OF ORDER.
AND I'M GONNA GO TO YOU.
ISSUE TEN CENTS A SENATOR
RICARDO IS HERE [inaudible]
AND THIS IS ON REQUEST FOR
FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY WATER.
TANKS WE ARE GOING TO HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN -- BUT WE'LL HEAR IT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THERE ARE YOU HAVE FULLER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR THE
INFORMATION THEY PROVIDED TO OUR
OFFICE ON DROUGHT RELIEF
PROGRAMS IN THE CURRENT WORK TO
PROVIDE.
ASSISTANCE TO MY CONSTITUENTS
AND SENATE DISTRICT.
FOURTEEN I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT OVERSIGHT ITEM THAT IS
DEEPLY IMPORTANT TO MY DISTRICT.
IN CALIFORNIA OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES HAVE NEEDED
EMERGENCY WATER TANKS AS A
RESULT OF HONEST HIS HISTORIC
DROUGHT.
ALTHOUGH THE DROUGHT WAS THE
CLERK OVER IN APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WATER SHORTAGE IS A
CHRONIC SYMPTOMS IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
GROUND WATER MOVES MUCH MORE
SLOWLY THAN SURFACE WATER AND IT
TAKES TIME FOR GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE OF WELLS TO OCCUR.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY FAMILIES
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO RELY
ON WELLS FOR THEIR DRINKING
WATER ARE STILL IN NEED OF
INTERMITTENT.
EVEN THOUGH THE DROUGHT HAS BEEN
DECLARED OVER.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO INSTALL
TEMPORARY WATER TANKS IN THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY.
HOWEVER ABOUT FORTY FAMILIES IN
MY DISTRICT CONTINUE TO SUFFER
FROM THE AFTERMATH OF THE GEL.
OF THE DROUGHT AS FUNDS WERE NOT
BEING ALLOCATED TO FAMILIES WHO
DIDN'T GO TRY UNDER THE DROUGHT
DECLARATION.
UNTIL LAST WEEK IT WAS UNCLEAR
WHETHER THESE FORTY FAMILIES
WOULD BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
INTERIM WATER TANK AS A PROGRAM
WAS IN ALLOCATING FUNDS TO
FAMILIES WHOSE.
WELLS WENT DRY AFTER ABLE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE END OF THE DROUGHT
DECLARATION.
I WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
DECLARATION ON MARCH TWENTY
FIRST WHICH ALLOCATED ADDITIONAL
EMERGENCY FUNDS TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
HOWEVER MY ASK OF A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND OF THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS THAT WE EXPEDITE
THESE FUNDS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
INSTALLATION OF WATER TANKS FOR
HOMES THAT STILL HAVE NO WATER.
WHETHER THEY'RE WELLS WENT DRY
UNDER THE DROUGHT DECLARATION OR
NOT.
THE FACT F THE MATTER IS THAT
THERE ARE FAMILIES IN MY
DISTRICT THAT TO THIS DAY DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER IN
THEIR HOMES.
I ASK YOU THAT YOU DO EVERYTHING
YOU CAN TO MAKE SURE THESE FORTY
FAMILIES IN MY DISTRICT ARE FOR
IT SOME SOME.
SMALL RELIEF AND HAVE ACCESS TO
AND FROM WATER TANKS.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE TAMMY BUT
MAY WITH SELF HELP ENTERPRISES
TO HELP ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MEMBERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
CONSIDERATION OF THIS RISK
REQUEST -- WE DID RECEIVE
NOTIFICATION ON TUESDAY THAT WE
HAVE.
THE OFFICE OR OF THE REGION'S
THEIR BUSINESS RELEASE THE FUNDS
TO US IN ORDER TO PUT TING FOUND
ON THE GROUND.
I'M WE DO HAVE A VERY SHORT TIME
FRAME TO DO THAT.
I THINK THAT IN AND NOW I THINK
I KNOW IT DOES IN.
TWELVE THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
MY NAME'S TAMMY MCVEIGH WITHOUT
HELP ENTERPRISE.
I AM THE MANAGER OF DROUGHT
SERVICES.
ADAM SO I OVER I JUST STARTED
OVERSEEING THE WE PUT THE TANK
PROGRAM IN WITH OUR WELL PROGRAM
IT JUST.
CLOSE SO WE STARTED OVERSEEING
THIS AND WE NOTICED.
THERE WERE A LOT OF ISSUES WITH.
LACK OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN --
YES AND SELF HELP ENTERPRISES
NOT.
I GUESS MAYBE NOT UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE NEED WAS THERE WE START
PUSHING.
ONLY THIRTY MEETING AND I GUESS
SHARING THAT DISCUSSION THAT.
WE HAVE MANY FAMILIES I THINK
THERE WAS AN UNDERSTANDING THERE
WERE NOT SO MANY FAMILIES OUT
THERE.
BUT ACTUALLY WE SIGN INCREASE IN
THE NEED ACT.
THE DECLARATION WAS LIFTED
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN FAMILIES ARE
REALLY BEING AFFECTED.
HELLO WE DO HAVE A TIME FRAME TO
GET IT.
SO YOU DID RECEIVE NOTICE JUST
LAST TUESDAY THAT I DID RECEIVE
A IT'S AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT
NOPE NOT LAST TUESDAY JUST. TWO
DAYS -- OKAY YES -- IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION AND WILL HAPPEN UNTIL
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
SPEND [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
SO IT'S POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THAT.
WE MAY NOT.
NEED TO DO.
THE REALLOCATION.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO DO THAT REALLOCATION
HOWEVER I'M I DON'T.
SEE BASED ON WHAT WE SEE.
EVERY SINGLE DAY WE RECEIVE AT
LEAST THREE TO FOUR CALLS AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE STILL GOING.
IF WE CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH --
AND THAT'S JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
JUST THEY'RE JUST STARTING TO
HEAR ABOUT.
IF WE CAN TEN YEAH ON THE ACT.
I DON'T THINK THAT.
THE END I DON'T THINK THE FUNDS
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
WILL.
LAST UNTIL THE END OF TWENTY
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON FIND
PARTY CALLED.
DO YOU THINK SHE I'M.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF OKAY AND THE FOREIGN
MINISTER LA OF RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR INFORMING US.
AND THE WORD AS I INDICATED WHEN
WE OPENED WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT
OPEN.
BUT I THINK WE UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUE.
MUCH BETTER NOW THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OKAY SO WE'LL NOW RETURN BACK.
IN THE ORDER.
AND THAT IS ISSUE EIGHTY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIM ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM.
AND THIS -- ONE JUST FOR
COLLEAGUES KNOW THIS IS A WE WE
COULD CALL IT AN ONGOING PROGRAM
EXCEPT THAT [inaudible]
LAST YEAR -- IT CAME TO OUR
ATTENTION DURING THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THE GRANTS.
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
AND I THINK I WAS ONE OF THOSE
WHERE PEOPLE DIDN'T REALLY
REALIZE AND I I AM NOW NOT
RECALLING WHETHER WE WERE ABLE.
TO RESTORE WE DID SO WE TOOK AYE
ACTION IN THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
AND GOT DEFINING IN THERE I
THINK WAS SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
TO REALIZE WAS IN ALREADY IN THE
BUDGET.
AND THIS ACTION IS JUST TO
CONTINUE ABOUT WHICH WE'VE BEEN
DOING AND HOPEFULLY GET US IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO
BE ALERTED AND THREE CAR FOR ME
THAT SOMEHOW IT WAS INCLUDED.
SO GO AHEAD.
AT THE SOUTH CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AGAIN AS YOU MENTIONED
THIS IS JUST A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL.
TO PROVIDE ONGOING SUPPORT FOR
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROGRAM.
IT'S BEEN.
WE'VE BEEN FUNDED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN BY LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATIONS OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ACCEPT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WHERE THE
APPROPRIATE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IT SUPPORTS TWENTY ONE PROJECTS
STATE WIDE.
AND FOR THE USE OF THE FUNDS TO
DATE ONLY THE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
FUNDS HAVE BEEN CLOSED OUT AN OF
THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
WERE AWARDED.
LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
WERE WERE REVERTED.
HE SAID HOW MUCH LESS THAN WHAT
SAY THAT AGAIN LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WERE REVERTED.
IN TEN MILLION IN THIS SO FAR
THIS FISCAL YEAR BUT NOW FOR THE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN ALLOCATION WE
GOT THAT'S THE ONLY YEAR WHERE
THE FUNDS -- WHERE WE DOWN RIGHT
AND THAT OF COURSE WAS THE FIRST
YEAR?
RIGHT SO IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT SO FAR IT'S BEEN A
CONSISTENT THEME HEARD THROUGH
THERE THAT THOSE THINGS THAT WE
GIVE THE ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING.
TO I EVEN NINE MONTHS INTO THE
YEAR OF NOT USE THAT MUCH OF
THEIR ONE FAMILY FUNDING
[inaudible]
I'M.
BUT I'M ASSUMING THAT IN THAT.
IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE THAT MONEY
WAS WELL MAYBE IT WAS A RE
PROCREATIVE BUT THE FOLLOWING
YEAR WE DID GIVE THAT A FIVE
MILLION [inaudible]
ALLOCATION.
I'D WE GOT US ANOTHER TEN
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION THE
NEXT YEAR OKAY BUT THEN A FIVE
YEAR AND SEVENTEEN OKAY. FIVE
MILLION NOT A FIVE YEAR FIVE
MILLION RIGHT.
WOULD WICH MIGHT OF AND I
CANNOT REMEMBER MIGHT HAVE
REFLECTED THAT THERE WERE SOME
UNUSED FUNDS.
AT I'M NOT SURE OKAY OKAY.
BUT IT THIS REQUEST IS TO
CONTINUE THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
THAT WE INITIALLY APPROPRIATE IN
AN AGAIN APPROPRIATED LAST YEAR.
FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM OKAY.
HERNIA DOESN'T HAVE THE CPT BUT
ANYWAY LA -- THAT WAS OUR MAIN
COMMON IS IS THIS WAS ANOTHER
ONE THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE BC HE
WAS A CONTINUATION OF CERTAINLY
SOME AUGMENTATIONS LEGISLATURE'S
MADE IN PAST YEARS -- ONE POINT
THAT WE WOULD MAKE ON ON THIS
APPROACH SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
ON THAT MIGHT BE -- ENVISIONED
AS PART OF THIS PROGRAM
POTENTIALLY COULD ALSO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES A. B.
C. P. COULD.
COULD HELP OUTLINED -- THERE ARE
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES THAT ARE
EXPECTED IN FEDERAL FUNDS.
OR DO WE THAT THE STATE ACTUALLY
JUST RECEIVED RECENTLY ON
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME ACT FUNDS.
ARE THE STATE LAST YEAR HAD
ABOUT GOT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A LITTLE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION THIS YEAR I'M
THE TO THAT -- I SHOULD SAY THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALLOCATION
WAS ALMOST DOUBLE THAT IT WAS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION SO
THERE IS A REALLY SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN FUNDING ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE THAT CAN BE USED
FOR DIRECT.
SERVICES TO VICTIMS INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY SOME SERVICES FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO JUST WANT
TO BRING THAT TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION AND
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING WE
THINK A COULD BE CONSIDERED AS A
FUNDING SOURCE FOR THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY.
WELL WE COULD ALWAYS IN.
THE FINAL.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
YOU KNOW IT.
HAVE SOME DIRECTION ROOM
PURSUING NOT REDUCING THE TEN
MILLION WITH ALLOCATE BUT
PURSUING.
FEDERAL IN OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
YOUR LAST FOR PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE DURING THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE LAST YEAR
WE HAD.
LOTS OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
OF DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THAT WERE
PARTNERING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE PARTNERING WITH CITY OR
COUNTY AGENCIES THAT WERE
PROVIDING.
THAT WERE UTILIZING THE FINDING.
FOR SUPPORTING OUR AT PROVIDING
SERVICES AND OTHER SUPPORTS FOR
A VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
EVEN TO THE POINT OF PROVIDING
INTERVENTIONS AND REMOVAL OF THE
FOLKS AND THEN HOUSING FOR THEM
BECAUSE CLEARLY ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE PRIMARY -- WAYS THAT SOME
THAT THE PERSON IS BEING TRAFFIC
TICKETS.
PULLED INTO THAT TRACKING IS
BECAUSE OF LACK OF RESOURCES
THEMSELVES SO -- WELL I COULDN'T
SIT HERE AND GIVE YOU SPECIFIC
DATA ABOUT THE DEMAND ON THE
SERVICES.
AT LEAST IN THE PUBLIC HEARING.
IN THE COMMENTS THAT WE HEARD AT
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE THIS
QUITE SIGNIFICANT SO IT
OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE'D WANT TO
PURSUE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FIND.
FEDERAL ANOTHER FUNDING FOR WERE
AVAILABLE.
AND I'M HERE JUST ONE THING A
PLANNED OUT ON THAT IF WE CAN
FUNDING PROGRAMS WITH GENERAL
FUND WE CAN'T THEN.
TRANSITION OUT TO FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE WOULD BE SEEN AS A PLAN
TEAMS WE JUST HAVE TO BE CARRIED.
OUT HOW WE DO BUT WE CAN TRY IF
PURSUE MATCHING FUNDS I WAS NOT
LOOKING AT IT AS A REDUCTION NO
BUT RATHER HEY WE EXPAND OUR
ABILITY THAT'S ALL.
ANY CMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
BEFORE I ASK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIS IS THE CENTER ABOUT IN MY
DISTRICT THIS IS THE A MASSIVE
ISSUE [inaudible]
AND THIS.
SLAVERY EXISTED IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH IN ALL FORMS IN TERMS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING JUST JUST.
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
SO OFTEN WORKER TRAFFICKING THIS
TERRIBLE AMIDST.
MASSIVE IT'S A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
WE STARTED TO SEE IT IN RUSSIAN
SAY STARTED WE'VE UNCOVERED IT
AND HAD OPENED OUR EYES TO THE
FACT THAT IT'S NOT JUST THAT
TRAFFICKING THERE'S ALSO.
AT ILLEGAL OPERATIONS THAT
UTILIZE PEOPLE -- IN EFFECT LIKE
SLAVE LABOR.
I'M PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SIDE
OF NICOLE ORTOLAN ON BEHALF OF
THE AND BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND PORT UP THE
ON GO FUNDING -- SOME OF THE
BEST A LIST AND IT'S BEEN
UTILIZED THIS CRISIS HOTLINES
EMERGENCY SHELTER TEMPORARY
HOUSING.
EMERGENCY FOOD INCLUDING
COUNSELING TRANSPORTATION.
IT IT RUNS THE GAMUT AND IT'S
DEFINITELY UTILIZED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE CARRERA
REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO VERY
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL AND ALSO
MAKING IT A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION.
OF BECAUSE THIS IS NOT YOU KNOW
YEAR TO YEAR BUT MAKING
CONTINUOUS SO THAT THE AGENCIES
HAVE A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING THIS PROBLEM IS NOT
GOING AWAY.
ANYTIME SOON WE KNOW IT'S A
CONTINUOUS -- DEMAND FOR THE
SUPPORT ON THAT THESE AGENCIES
NEED SO WE ASK FOR A BETTER
THANK YOU.
BUT AFTERNOON CUSTOMS ACOSTA
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS TED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF MANY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SERVING TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS ARE ALSO SERVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
EVER IS.
AND YOU KNOW WE WERE THRILLED TO
SEE THIS MONEY BACK IN
CONFERENCE GLAD TO SEE IT AND AT
THE BUDGET FROM THE BEGINNING
AND AS AN ONGOING REQUEST THAT
CAN PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY AND
STABILITY TO THE PROGRAMS THAT
RELY ON THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN FINLEY
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL SALTS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE ONGOING BUDGET PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO I'M WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED.
RIGHT WE HAVE THAT MOTION WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL UNDERSTANDING
HI AND MARLA [inaudible]
SENATOR ABOUT.
ALRIGHT OUR LAST ITEM IS THE
CORRECT OUR LAST ITEM.
SENATOR BELT.
ACTUAL ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PREVENTION FUNDING AND YOU'RE
FREE TO PRESENT RIGHT WHERE YOU
ARE -- THANK YOU MAN SURE AS
****.
EVERYBODY'S AND OCEAN I'M JUST
GONNA BE VERY BRIEF -- I WORKING
ALONGSIDE WITH -- ASSEMBLY WOMAN
OF BLANCA RUBIO. TO SECURE A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR DOMESTIC.
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ALONG WITH THE TEN OTHER
LEGISLATORS.
OF WE WOULD WHEN WE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT IN
PREVENTION.
IT'S RIGHT NOW OF FOR THE FAMILY
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHICH FOCUSES ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ZERO TOWARDS SEXUAL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
AND WE INVEST NOTHING AND SEXUAL
BUT YOU REQUEST A MEN'S AND
RENAMES OF FAMILY VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
SEXUAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
VALIUM AFFECTS THE SURVIVOR
INFECTS EVERYONE FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW
WE'RE THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WE'RE SUPPOSED.
TO WORK TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE.
BUT OF IN WE HAVE THE ALL THE
BILLIONS.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THE AS YET YET TO SEXUAL
VIOLENCE OF AND A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROGRAMS.
WHICH OFTEN OR NOT PROSECUTE
THERE'S SELDOM PROSECUTED.
OF WE HAVE TO APPROACH IN A IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WAY.
AND THIS IS THIS IS THE WAY IS
TO FOCUS ON PREVENTION IT'S GOT
TO BE THE THE WAY BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT
PROSECUTED.
JUST HAVE TO REALIZE THAT'S YOU
KNOW THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S A HIGH.
OF HILL WE HAVE TO CLIMB AND
HOPEFULLY CAN CLIMB TO GET
BETTER PROSECUTION BETTER
EVIDENCE BUT BUT RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE WE HAVE TO PROVOKE.
PROMOTE THE PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
OF WE SHOULD NOT WAIT TILL THE
PROBLEM HAS OCCURRED COURSE TO
TRY TO HELP PEOPLE WE NEED TO
START AT THE VERY BEGINNING AND
STOP.
VIOLENCE BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
THE CLUSTER A STATE IN HOLE IN
ECONOMIC TERMS -- ONE HUNDRED
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS.
ARE WE OWE IT TO OUR USE THEIR
SURVIVORS.
ARE COMMUNITIES TO INVEST IN
PREVENTION EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
PROMOTING HEALTHY RELATIONSHIPS
AFTER COMMUNITIES.
ELIMINATING DISMISSIVE AND
DISCRIMINATORY LANGUAGE.
IN ADDITION TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND SERVICES
PROGRAMS AN ORGANIZATION.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES EDUCATING
YOUTH ON HEALTHY SAFE
RELATIONSHIP SKILLS.
IT PROVOKED OF RIGHTS PATHWAYS
TO PROGRAMS IMPROVES OUR SCHOOLS
AND SAFETY.
OF WHY IS THIS SUCH A BIG BUDGET
ITEM WELL IF IF WE COULD DO THE
PREVENTION WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO SAVE MONEY ALL KINDS OF OTHER
PLACES.
WE'RE GOING TO SAVE MONEY AND
CHILD SUPPORT AYE AYE AYE AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISORS OR MORE LIKE
WAS.
MISSION IS.
THE FAMILY AND IT'S USED TO
COERCE PEOPLE INTO.
NOT NOT COMPLAINING WHEN.
WHEN CHILD SUPPORT ISN'T?
AND AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA'S ONE
OF THE WORST STATES IN TERMS OF
COLLECTION OF CHILD SUPPORT WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY -- IN A HORRIBLE
STATE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
COLLECTIONS COMPARED TO OTHER
FIFTY STATES.
SO I I JUST WANT TO USE THAT
EXAMPLE BUT I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT OTHER THINGS IN TERMS OF
OF THE AFFECTED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ON EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT.
WE HAVE OUR OUR SURGEON GENERAL
IS TALKING ABOUT ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES IN.
TERMS FOR MATIC EXPERIENCE THE
KIDS HAVE AND WHAT THE IMPACT IS.
A IT ACTUALLY DESTROYS THE
EDUCATION.
IT IMPACTS THE EDUCATION BECAUSE
THE CHILDREN CANNOT FOCUS WHEN
THEIR FAMILIES OF UNDERGOING --
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THAT'S A
PROVEN FACT ALSO SO SO IN TERMS
OF OF COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE OF
HUGE.
PROBLEMS WITH THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IT IT HAS A HUGE IMPACT
ON EDUCATION.
AND AND IT'S NOT RECOGNIZED.
AND I I THINK WE HAVE TO SPUR
RECOGNIZING IT AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT SO.
THIS IS THE PROPOSAL AND OF I
THINK IT WOULD -- HELP WORK OUR
STATE -- ALTERNATE -- IN THAT
TURNED OVER TO OF THE SPEAKERS
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MY NAME
IS KRISTEN I'M STUCK WITH
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE -- HERE ON
THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
I THINK IT IS TO BUILD ON WHAT
THE SENATOR SAID THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
WOULD BE FOR ON GOING FUNDING
ADMINISTERED AS COMPETITIVE
GRANTS THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES -- WHICH AS
YOU ALL KNOW ON THE COMMITTEE.
CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS MUCH OF
THE DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
FUNDING -- ABIDE MINISTER IN
COMPETITIVE GRANTS OUT TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY IS THE PROGRAM
ALLOWS -- COMMUNITY IS TO REALLY
GROUND TO THEIR PREVENTION
EFFORTS AND WHAT WORKS FOR THEIR
DISTRACTED THEIR REGION.
WE SEE A GREAT WORK WITH YOUTH
AROUND IT USE LEADERSHIP EMPOWER
MEN -- WE SEE IT WORK HAPPENING
WITH THE COACHES AND ATHLETICS.
REALLY YOU KNOW.
BUILDING COACHES AS LEADERS TO
HELP.
WITH THE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
REALLY ESTABLISHING WHAT HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS AND WELL BEING CAN
LOOK LIKE.
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE ARE
DEEPLY GROUNDED IN A RANGE OF
ISSUES THAT ARE IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITY IS AND WHAT WE KNOW IS
THAT WHEN WE FOCUS ON PREVENTION
NOT ONLY DO WE REDUCE THE COST
OF THE SENATOR SPOKE ABOUT.
FOR THE COST OF CRISIS SERVICES
WHICH IS COMMITTEE HAS LONG
SUPPORTED BUT ALSO COSTS OF
INCARCERATION PROSECUTION.
MEDICAL NEEDS OF SURVIVORS --
BUT WHEN WE CAN PREVENT A
MUSTARD VIOLENCE WE ALSO PREVENT
MASS SHOOTINGS -- OVER HALF OF
MASS SHOOTINGS ORIGINATE IN A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DISAPPEAR.
WHEN WE PREVENT MASTIC BALANCE
BE PER VAN -- A WHOLE RANGE OF
FIRE ARMS -- DEATHS WE PROVIDES --
YOU KNOW OF WHEN WE ADDRESS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION WE
ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF SO MANY OF THE OTHER --
PROBLEMS PLAGUING OUR COMMUNITY
IS SO WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
SMART INVESTMENT THAT PAY IS
LONG TERM DIVIDENDS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE HEARING
FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING US TO BE HERE MY NAME
IS JOHN FINLEY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO HEAR
FROM ONE OF OUR MEMBER PROGRAMS
WHO I HAD HOPED TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF YOU ALL THE
DAY UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO STEP
OUT.
BUT I THINK IT'S MORE POWERFUL
HEARING FROM THEM THE WORK.
SACRAMENTO SOUL RAPE CRISIS
CENTER AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THE MONEY YOU
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR TOWARDS
PREVENTION AND EDUCATION ON THE
ISSUES OF SEXUAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
BECAUSE OF THAT FUNDING AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS AND APPROACHES FOR
PREVENTING THIS TYPE OF VIOLENCE
AND EDUCATE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ON THESE ISSUES.
HOWEVER EVEN WITHOUT FUNDING WE
STILL DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
EDUCATORS BE IN ALL THE SCHOOLS
AND ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT NEED US.
WE'VE HERE IN SACRAMENTO IS
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE SOME
DIRECT FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
THE MANY AGENCIES DON'T HAVE SO
THIS NEW FUNDING WOULD BE VITAL
IN EXPANDING THOSE EFFORTS.
BECAUSE OF MY PRESENCE IN THE
SCHOOLS I'VE SEEN HOW PREVENTION
HAS A DIRECT IMPACT ON CHANGING
ATTITUDES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
SEXUAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
WITH THE LAST SIX MONTHS ON ONE
OF THE CAMPUSES I'VE SEEN
STUDENTS WHO STARTED OUR PROGRAM
WITH LITTLE TO NO KNOWLEDGE OF
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY EARLY
WARNING SIGNS OF THESE THINGS.
NOT ONLY IN THEIR OWN LIVES BUT
ALSO AND BROADER SOCIETY.
THIS WE'RE GOES BEYOND JUST
CLASSROOMS WE HAVE CLUBS AN
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THIS KIND OF EDUCATION IN AND
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM.
OUR CAPACITY TO DO PREVENTION
WORK WOULD BE EXPANDED WITH
INCREASED FUNDING ALLOW FOR MORE
EDUCATORS TO BE IN MORE SCHOOLS
AND MORE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMMUNITY IS NO THERE IS A
NEED FOR THIS EDUCATION NOT IT'S
HELP IN PREVENTING THESE ISSUES
AND CONTINUING WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME AND RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO GO ALL THE PLACES WE ARE
ASKED AND WHERE WE ARE NEEDED.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR TIME IS
VALUABLE AND APPRECIATE YOU ALL
AGAIN FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
DISCUSS SUCH AN IMPORTANT MATTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M TO HAVE MANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER
STATION **** ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUDGET ALLOCATION AND ALL OF THE
GREAT WORK THAT CAN BE DONE WITH
THIS FUND.
THANK YOU.
I WORRY WE ARE HOLDING IT OPEN
BUT HAPPY TO HAVE -- ANY
QUESTIONS IF.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I'M.
CENTER BELL FOR PRESENTING AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ALSO.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE COMPLETED
OUR AGENDA ITEMS. FOR OUR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
FIVE EVERYONE ENJOY THE WEEKEND
AND WE WILL BE STAND -- JURORS